oh here we go good hello Jimmy
hi Joe what's going on Bobby good to see
ya good to see you well we were just
talking about the the air force
admitting that their pilots had seen
UFOs and you were telling me you
interviewed one of those pilots I
interviewed commander flavor and he was
saying that this the chocolate has been
my favorite it's with an R free forever
flavor okay he was taught that mean he
was one of the guys that actually went
to what is the word they do when they
scramble and go to try to figure out
what the [ __ ] something is but they they
monitored this thing they saw it with
their eyes they saw it with their
equipment it was actively jamming the
radar whatever this thing was it shaped
like a tic-tac and it moved so fast you
couldn't track it with the human eye
they said it went from I think they said
some some impossible number like 60,000
feet down at 200 feet in less than a
second like whatever you could track you
know a radar as a blip blip blip blip
they don't know how fast it actually
went they just know it went this insane
distance in less than a second less than
a radar jump thank you it would it would
dated had observed them in that area
without his knowledge like other Air
Force pilots had observed them and then
had you know brought it up the top of
the food chain but it wasn't something
that got distributed to everybody until
he saw it when he saw he was like what
in the [ __ ] am I looking at here and
they're like we have we've been seeing
these things and this thing with no
active propulsion system that you could
recognize there was nothing around no
fire coming out of it nothing around and
it would just just disappear just take
off at insane race to speed and actively
jamming the radar so when I covered this
on my show I said now I've heard reports
that pilots see this stuff all the time
but they never confirmed it and my
question was why now why would the Air
Force be confirming that they saw UFOs
nagas again like they've been there's
been reports that pilots have seen this
stuff forever I'm not saying it didn't
happen I'm saying why are they
it happen now and then of course you see
in this last defense budget they put in
money for space for mmm I think the
money for the space force though isn't
that because China is able to whatever
they can do to make sure we want to
spend more money that's what they'll do
they we saw UFO hey Chyna
Hey look over there we got to spend more
money that's what's flavor I guarantee
you isn't in that no no I guarantee no
no they're just now but before they
would say that's not true they're there
for us we'll go we don't acknowledge
that and now they're gonna acknowledge
it right you're probably right it's
probably something to that that it's
just about budgets and I just I want it
I don't want to be that cynical when it
comes to something like that
really that's cynical I want to think
come on that's not cynical that nothing
plus to it is you're right but it's also
cynical it's the only reason why they're
telling us is because of how it's it's
both things yeah okay I it is to point I
mean look it's a hundred percent is well
how they do it if they need some sort of
justification for expanding their reach
or expanding their budget they come up
with some threat well this is this joke
is just what I keep telling people and
no one seems to think this is a big deal
but you know the Democrats and the
mainstream news have spent the last
three years telling everybody that Trump
is a Manchurian Candidate he's a traitor
to our country and working under the
behest of Vladimir Putin and while
they're impeaching him they're voting to
give them an extra 131 billion dollars
to go bomb anybody he wants and if he's
bombing at the behest of Vladimir Putin
why would you give an extra 131 billion
dollars now let me tell you how much 131
billion dollars is Joe please do well 20
million dollars would adding
homelessness and homelessness yeah
is that real though that's that's that's
the way to get to that in a moment but
that's let's just say it's 20 let's just
say it's 20 billion a year a year not
just once but every year you'd have to
spend 20 billion okay guess what they're
spending an extra 131 billion since
Trump took office every year going
forward on bomb 131 billion each so
everybody's at college 110 billion
we'd have no homeless people yes if they
took that money and put it towards it
that's a lot so somebody told me the
difference between a million and a
billion so I read this so the I don't
know maybe you want a fact check
I'm not full of [ __ ] again but so like a
million seconds would be like eleven
days but a billion seconds is like 33
years yeah something like that I'm not
sure if that but it's close yeah
so that's a hundred and thirty 1 billion
dollars could do a lot of good things
you know we could have our military
budget and still we'd still be spending
most more than any other country now why
do you think that they would do that why
do you think while they're impeaching
him they would also approve this
incredible budget increase for military
because they're owned right by the
military-industrial complex that's why
because they you know that's the defense
secretaries could just came right from
Raytheon right the guy before it was
Secretary of State came right from Exxon
I mean come on that that's the beauty of
Trump is like you'd have to figure it
out they asked him the other day about
you know his criticisms of how he's
handling he goes you know where where
they said I didn't pull out of Syria and
I did but I left troops for the oil
they're just there to guard the oil and
it's like he just says it so which a
proves he's the funniest president we've
ever had oh for sure oh no doubt no
doubt no doubt I thought George Bush was
funny
this guy he's intentionally and
unintentionally the funniest president
you've ever had like the other day he
was doing a signing last so in 2019 was
the hundred sentence 100-year
anniversary the centennial anniversary
of women getting the right to vote
women's suffrage so he was signing a
thing commemorating it the hundred year
they're gonna have a coin and as he said
he goes you know I heard they been
working on getting this done for a long
time I wonder why it finally happened
now because it's Centennial is now dummy
you can tell why didn't a hundred years
happen faster and he's sitting around
going well we get stuff done that's why
it happened and they're all look at him
like okay mr. president but he Street
faces it it's hilarious do you think
he's on speed and somebody oh well so
when he did that one video with a drawer
with the drawer opens actually a photo
was a photo when he was eating that talk
all right that's it I love Hispanics
remember that it was after he said some
rude [ __ ] about Mexicans say does this
taco bowl thing say that with Trump
Tower is the best taco bowls I love a
spam
yes and the drawer was open and you saw
he had that stuff from England or
whatever right the super red super
powerful pseudo F adrene which is
essentially a type of speed well it's I
like him on speed better than the other
guy
I like the speedy speedy Trump he's
entertaining well sometimes it wears off
though and you see him slurring as well
he really doesn't even try to finish
words sometimes try but he have a hard
time with words I was the one word him
and George Bush both osa brontë they
both sovereign was that one David Pakman
put a video up it showed all the
different times that Trump has struggled
to talk but there's one that's really
disturbing because it's obvious he's
under some sort of sedative or he's
coming down from some speed and he's
barely staying awake while he's talking
it's like if you were calling if you
called me at 3 o'clock in the morning
and I just worked 24 hours in a row and
you like hey man what are you doing
literally like really but you never seen
no I haven't seen it no see if he could
find it because it's it's really bonkers
because when you hear I'm talking like
oh my god like this and there was no
discussion of this it's not like he came
out later and said hey guys I had a bad
night last night somebody slipped me a
Mickey it was a real issue well his
whole thing is he's a teetotaler right
Trump does nonsense is it yeah the the
pseudo ever dream oh but then it turns
out he's doing you know pharmaceuticals
yes yeah he's doing what's legal that's
what it is yeah you know if you you the
doctor writes up a prescription
you know there was this whole thing with
what was that there was a reporter that
named the Duane Reade pharmacy that he
had gone to in New York to fill this
prescription for a metabolic condition
which he said is like a [ __ ] reason
it was like he took diet pills and this
diet pills were speed but it was
prescribed by his doctor but look if
you're a guy who want to [ __ ] get
[ __ ] done all yeah you want to be on
speed I know people way to go I know
people who say they write songs on speed
like that I you know need a musician
Slayer I don't know Slayer but music
oh okay you know yeah that speed music I
don't know what the kids list Sarah
McLaughlin on speed I imagine she's like
[ __ ] those puppies yeah you know I I I
went to one of those uh what they called
the woman's Lollapalooza what were they
called Lilith Lilith I was dating a girl
oh and she took me Oh
chewing oh my god she's just trying to
drain you turns out I was going through
mentally imbalanced time I didn't know
that I was like oh I was that was what I
was going through a nervous breakdown
music to listen to it was that no but I
do remember the what's that hard rocking
woman who's really good middle there's
one that's really good Chrissy Chrissy
Hynde yeah from the pretenders that's it
yeah she's a beast that she was there
that I'm like this is good oh yeah I was
like that's really good ya know I always
loved her yeah she's awesome I was like
let's just have her play more yeah what
the [ __ ] is this I can't remember who
else was there
Oh anytime you have all woman's anything
or an all man's anything for that matter
it's a mess like if you say this is a
men's conference we're here for men that
you're gonna find a bunch of bitch-ass
men too you're not gonna find any real
men and all men's get away let's get
together and talk about our problems and
they're all they all stem from [ __ ]
yeah
[ __ ] us it's a horrible situation I
don't know how I don't know how a women
I just feel sorry for women that I have
to [ __ ] men I do it don't you
we're gross no kidding no kidding and do
you ever just listen the way guys talk
to women trying to get laid it's like oh
my god really dumb guys that which is
most guys most guys most people yeah
most men and women are dumb yes fact
yeah I would I would I'm close I'm ever
in the dumber yeah I put it down there's
gaps in my knowledge that I can't
believe oh yeah and will neither /
neither of us are gonna figure anything
out we're not that guy that they're
gonna call on there's a real issue we
need jimmy dore no but that's but that's
see that's the thing Joe but my whole
show is that someone as dumb as me can
see through this yes I can picked it I
can put it together
oh we're gonna admit that we have UFOs
and now we're gonna have a space bar
okay I can put that together that's the
whole thing it's like if I can do this I
know they can do this they're just not
doing it
I think the UFO thing is you know I know
you're probably right in terms of like
one of the reasons why they released it
but I think there's also this when you
get a bunch of like really credible
people like that commander flavor guy
when you get actual data like radar you
actually could look at the video of the
infrared infrared camera of them
tracking that thing there's enough of
those now that people are like well what
the [ __ ] is going on and if you guys
have all this money and all this
equipment is this is this something that
the Chinese are doing or the Russians
are doing or is this something that you
can't explain and I think we're in this
area where there's so much information
people who can get ahold of so many
videos and so much stuff that they kind
of have to start talking about it now
okay I you know I I see how they shut
down conversations around the most
innocuous of enquiries so that's true
too they can just a shame pretty hard
yeah they that that's pretty that's true
too but when you got a guy who's like a
decorated pilot like flavor mm-hmm and
he's like look I'm I don't many other
crazy stories in my past he's not crazy
guys
rocks
a general all-around American hero type
guy he's like look I'll tell you what I
[ __ ] saw and it's pretty crazy about
those pilots though they look like to
pay them up crazy life they don't think
well they have to go and write faster
than the speed of sound Oh sex it dawn
with the the book yeah um look Chris is
a good friend of mine I think there's
some of the things that Chris looks at
like Chris is kind of freak he wants
things to be a little on the freaky side
yeah but the idea about the pilots is
that they all swap slopes my wife
swapping because they think they could
die at any moment and they they I create
this bond yes yeah they want someone to
love their wife as much as they do or
maybe they want to [ __ ] their buddy's
wife joke there are Trump's diet pills
and then what a Badgers wife so you
don't think that happened probably sure
happens oh yeah especially during
wartime yeah
war war people shift war is crazy you
know the the mind shifts when you see
bodies when you've killed people when
you've made these rationalizations and
also you're very aware that someone's
trying to do to you what you've done to
people and your entire existence is you
know from dawn till dusk is eliminate
the enemy and this it's a it's a mindset
that people slide right into it's my
doctor dr. Sharpe that [ __ ] guy
Sharpe just kidding dr. Sharpe doc
Sojin so dr. Charles Sharpe was uh he's
the guy he's the greatest
endocrinologist drunk Charles John
Darrell that guy he's new he's in
Pasadena Alta I almost said Pasadena ah
if you said ivories out [ __ ] what at
Glendale cuz it's funnier ah I always go
Glendale I always go Glendale and then
then it a go
Glendale and then Torrance those words
is a good one Jones is good it's like
why you living there what do you what do
you wouldn't need a Pinto and Taurus
anyway so um what was I talking about
you dr. Sharpe oh so he said he smoked
pot in when he
in Vietnam because I told them I smoked
pot right just to let him know
everything that's happening with me
chemically and he said that he said yeah
I did it I said you ever smoke he goes
yeah I did it once in Vietnam he said
they would have a helicopter circling
the medical he was a doctor in America
and so you could always hear it
constantly searching for whatever people
coming at us and then all of a sudden I
didn't hear it and it had crashed right
so I had to go help the guy and he said
I just smoked pot and as a doctor you
have to be able to disassociate from
what you're doing and he said I couldn't
and he said so when I came up on him and
I could tell this guy was going to be
crippled further and I couldn't it would
mess me up because so I never smoked pot
again Wow I could see I could you
imagine like you're new to pot you know
how it makes you sense things extra when
especially when you first start you know
how you just extra cent and then you
walk up on a scene like that like oh my
god I couldn't imagine that so that yeah
I probably was nothing yeah I mean
that's talking about bad trips bad bad
trip that's as bad as it gets
yeah walk up on someone who just crashed
in a helicopter in the middle of a war
and you you're you're high as [ __ ] and
you realize he's crippled so let me ask
you question when when you when I would
travel out of the country I would always
think that oh I get like a little cold
flu thing every time I travel out of the
country like I would get night sweats
and I would kind of get a headaches and
I would feel a little fluey you know and
then I got this dental implant and so I
didn't I so I want they say don't smoke
whenever so I'm like gonna be extra good
I didn't smoke for a whole week I felt
like I felt when I go out of Europe I
think you have a physical addiction yes
I was like no way did you I'm that's why
I won't ask is that ever happened to you
and you travel outside the country no no
but some people do have that apparently
yes like night sweats the worst nights
where you wake up and you're you know as
soon as I take this cover off it's gonna
be freezing yes I got to get up and
change my t-shirt and sleep in a t-shirt
and and jeans and I like to be read in
timberlands
what about now do you sleep before do
you smoke before you go to bed is that
your move of course okay so it helps you
sleep oh yeah
yeah how about you know it doesn't help
you sleep no no no when I smoke pot I'm
awake I start thinking about [ __ ] I
don't want to go to sleep oh it depends
when I smoke right so there's the thinkI
pot and then there's the shitty but even
the sleepy pot makes me sometimes it
gives me a burst and but then like I
smoke this stuff called GMO whoa it is
the best genetically modified organisms
oh I wonder if that's what it stands for
yeah exactly they're trying to [ __ ] with
you they're like this GMO [ __ ] son they
are [ __ ] with me well he's working
like they're genetically modifying the
weed for sure I was just don't forget
today I was just in port so I get this
at my place over in Eagle Rock so when I
was in Portland last weekend it's legal
so I just walk into a pot store and I go
ham looking for indica high THC he goes
how about GMO go you're getting [ __ ]
buried it was great how high is it it's
got like 29 percent THC what was that
[ __ ] that Kevin Smith dropped off wasn't
at 42% how do you get something
forty-two he's going hard
he's an all-day guy he's one of them all
day guys he starts off in the morning
just keep going yeah so that's the
problem with like I love to take a
little puff in the morning with my
coffee or what have you but the problem
is you're giving up your later night
buzz because I can't get buzz more than
once or twice a day that's it but cuz of
my tolerance and then if I try to smoke
more I'll just get headache yeah do you
ever get headaches no I don't get
headaches from party you don't get any
of these problems I just get the in the
over stimulation the I mean you would
call it paranoia but I kind of welcome
and sometimes because I think it's good
to be hyper aware of all these different
things and it makes you appreciate when
you're not you know I think that that
that feeling that you get when you get
high when you're like oh my god like
everything is [ __ ] dangerous the
world is a dangerous place and I'm gonna
die someday for sure everyone around me
is gonna die I hope they don't die today
and the crazy thing is like these
feelings for some reason aren't they
even though you know those things to be
a fact no like you know you're like a
basically like all we are all water
balloons they're like water balloons of
blood with like sticks holding us
together we're so doughy and fleshy and
weak and vulnerable and you know like
that guy found when he found that
helicopter dashed and that's that's what
happens to your body your body's a very
vulnerable thing it's not very tough
even the toughest bodies very vulnerable
yeah yeah I know I I watch boxing yeah
yeah see him go down oh yeah toughest
guys in the world but you know what I
always wondered what it I have been
knocked out you've been knocked out yes
okay so it's not a bit like when you get
knocked out and you wake up you don't
know you're like did I just get backed
out I never really completely
unconscious but I got TKO'd in a
kickboxing bout I got drop and then I
got I got hit with a bunch of other
punches and the referee stopped it oh
that was more like mine that wasn't
weird that was the worst feeling I had
ever had up to that moment it was like
my legs just stopped working my butt
they just shut off like this guy hit me
with a left hook I was conscious but my
legs just went whoop oh that's one agent
though his legs aren't there you always
heard them say that but like they go
they literally go out they go whoo did
you any of the power oh yeah they
stopped working it's very strange and
it's like your your brain gets jostle
around inside your head and also when
you get hit on the jaw there's nerves
behind your jaw when your bone of your
jaw slams into those nerves and your
head gets rattled in the brain all of it
together is like everything just goes
what's happening here you know sometimes
you get knocked unconscious I didn't get
knocked unconscious but my [ __ ] just
shut off I did I've always surprised
when guys get knocked out they don't
piss themselves I got and sometimes they
do they when they do they do a lot of
times when you choke him out oh really
yeah we choke guys out they piss
themselves all the time to [ __ ]
themselves too if they have to [ __ ]
really yeah yeah there's blood so deals
like before you go fight Dee try to make
sure you don't have to take a [ __ ] yeah
sometimes guys do have to take a [ __ ]
though like I've had guy at one time
michael Chiesa who's a top UFC fighter
he was right before he was fighting he
looked over at me like he's as he got
into the cage was dude he goes I'm gonna
[ __ ] myself he goes to guarantee I'm
gonna [ __ ] myself while his fights going
on my [ __ ] why wouldn't he just go to
the bath couldn't it was the way it
worked out like you know their call okay
you're wrong it's coming but you can't
go right oh no and then he just makes
the rock up there and then also wait
diaries like oh my god he went up
winning the fight but did he [ __ ] no he
didn't shoot himself huh I talked about
he's I was swore I was gonna [ __ ] myself
talked about him he's a funny dude no I
didn't talk about it I don't think I
said it I don't think I saw but I talked
to him I talked about it with him after
the fires like no I didn't shut myself
it would be funny we were laughing about
it if you could talk about it's like I
think I'm gonna have diarrhea let me
talk to you for a second
have you heard this story well if you do
you know if you have diarrhea it's like
it's one of those things man I'm I've
been on this carnivore diet do you know
what that is no I'm eating only meat for
the entire month of January just to see
what it's like no vegetables none zero
I had an olive and I had one piece of
chili mango actually a two pieces of
chili mango but uh and so is this good
for you that's where it gets weird it's
a really good question I don't know um I
don't even know how I feel about it so
what where did you get the idea to do it
everybody's doing it Oh real all the
kids okay so I did the Atkins thing I
did that like back in 2001 or something
when I needed to lose whatever I did
that and that that worked like it does
work it's very similar in that you know
you're just you're eliminating carbs
yeah you get your body to go into
ketosis you're getting to buy your body
to burn that's them yeah but it's the
thing about the carnivore diet though is
I actually checked my piss with a ketone
strip and it showed that I'm not in
ketosis so you pee on this you happy in
ketosis no I think it's because I'm
eating so much meat that when you have
too much protein there's something
called gluco gel assess I think it's
called where your body breaks the
protein down and turns it into glucose
and so that [ __ ] with your ketone
levels and that keeps you from going
into ketosis but it doesn't affect your
energy level my energy levels have been
amazing like all day long I'm flat I'm
sound like
people always ask me why do you always
have like that cough it's this goddamn
coffee his layered superfood coffee it
coats your throat it's delicious it is
delicious I love it when you said hey do
you do you like to Burak and you want it
in your coffee I'm like cut them what
the fuck'd in my head I was thinking
he's got today was there in the clothes
the [ __ ] tumeric tumeric goddamn
coffee come on
how good is it it is amazing it's
amazing but I drink too much of it and
I'm always like a little Flemmi because
yeah it's like in my throat
I'm not a big on American coffee but
this is Ventech American coffee how much
of his grown America mm sorry any coffee
groaning all I know is that when I go to
Italy and or if I go to Hawaii and I
have coffee it's always better no no
that's the best coffee on earth my
favorite coffee comes from Kona yeah
there's something about Hawaiian okay
it's the volcanic soil is that what it
is yeah and that same thing in Italy
that's why their tomatoes taste better
in their cars everything tastes better
it's the volcanic soil pretty sure what
does - [ __ ]
any questions I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say it makes some juicier I bet right
just like a piece of fruit or tomatoes
juicier
[Music]
I would so it so funny you say that
because I would just for out of nowhere
I started talking about on stage last
about how I you know I hate the word
vagina but I like [ __ ] the vagina word
is a weird word right cuz like who's
saying that other than a doctor right no
you never you never in the middle of sex
in her a woman goes thinking him like if
she did you'd go with you sure Oh what
are you doing I would say meaning with
me are you experimenting I don't think a
woman wants to hear that I mean maybe
they have like cute little names for
nicknames I had a job I had a joke where
I would say oh I get it
we were experimenting the other night my
wife and right in the middle of sex I
took it out and I stuck it in her vagina
Wow totally different looks like a glove
why are shot jokes but they're fun
they're fired and shocked oh they're fun
they're always been fun for me I don't
like when people say they're cheap like
no they're not cheap they're different
it's a different thing you know there's
really clever intellectual jokes and
those are great to write I love a good
[ __ ] up joke yeah especially because
you think it's going to be something
cleverer and that it's just a nope bad -
right in the face yeah that's funny to
me
it is funny yeah I'm a fan of all kinds
of jokes I like I like all kinds of
comedy and there's a while that we're
like dirty comedy was like looked down
upon as if it was easier well that it
was it was Dan Andrew Dice Clay so when
Andrew Dice Clay happens so a lot of
people started to ape him right because
he was very popular this is going back
in the early 90s yeah I know if you're
born yet and and so comedy clubs started
expanding and they had more clubs and
there were good comics so then they they
started to give free tickets away and so
they started to book they wanted more
generic acts that appeal to people who
weren't necessarily comedy fans or
whatever so this is my theory about what
happened and so then they would keep it
clean because we don't want to offend
anybody it's like that's not what [ __ ]
it that's not what people like then that
and you know that's why they all closed
and you know what my opinion on that is
I think bad comedy sucks but bad dirty
comedy makes you angry yeah that's what
it is well you know what's funny is I've
noticed this like if people watch a
musician go up and play like even an
open mic rotor and he plays a song or
two and you don't like him
you're still applaud after he's done
blowed up the comic goes up and he's not
funny it's like what people get angry
because you have to listen to the whole
thing he didn't talk during it yes awful
yeah so that it's I always noticed that
you could suck as a musician people will
still play you suck as a community like
this you know why also because if I go
to see a musician I really appreciate
the fact this person can play a musical
instrument which I can't do I have no
musical talent at all but I know how to
talk
I can talk everybody can talk and
everybody pretty much everybody said at
least one thing funny
at one point time so you know what it's
like when I say something and then it
gets a laugh you know you can do it
mm-hm
you know what they've done is just do it
more and really put a lot of time and do
it
you know craft and act but when that
acts terrible you start thinking I could
[ __ ] do that why am i listen to this
idiot well it was bad cut yeah so it was
bad comics that made me think I could do
comedy oh for sure open mic night right
oh no was watching it on TV oh so I
remember when I was in college we got
comedy like a cable in our dorm room
right and so I remember I was watching
the show I forget maybe what was that
one on a and he doesn't matter even with
the improv no it was that Rosie
O'Donnell 101 forgot about that yeah
Fridays or something
forget what it was called but stand-up
spotlight me yeah maybe I was on VH yeah
that was VH well vh1 was stand-up
spotlight yeah so anyway whatever so I'm
watching and i see this comic go up and
i'm he does like to jokes i beat him to
the punch line I'm on both of them right
I'm like he said what I thought he was
gonna say and then the third one wasn't
even funny he had inverted the punchline
which I didn't know that's what he did
but I go he should have put that thing
at the end and then I afterwards I go
wait a minute that guy I'm funnier than
that guy and he's on TV I think I could
do this yeah right like when I would go
to clubs I would go to zany's in Chicago
and those guys would just be whole area
and I'm like I could be funny for five
minutes at a party but I can't [ __ ]
do that right but I didn't realize they
were hot wet you'd do an act and you've
work and you do the whole thing and so
that's why I was like I can't do that
those guys are special funny and that I
saw guys on TV suck I'm like well I
could do that I might not be able to go
to zaydis but I could go to there was a
time during the 80s where there were so
many spots and so few comics that some
really mediocre comics not on television
yeah
really like mundane nonsense bits yes
and they all had that kind of comedy yes
well you're from Chicago too which is a
rough spot like it's [ __ ] cold there
people don't take any [ __ ] it's a
different kind of thing you know like
those are the kind of places that make
great comics like [ __ ] cult like
Boston same [ __ ] New York [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
hold and leave a little misery hey Hong
Kong [ __ ] you and you need a yes there
has to be a need for comedy yes
like I guys I say just in Hawaii we did
shows there I'm like man these
people are laid-back yeah it's not a lot
of great comics there's a few good
comics that come from Hawaii but not a
lot yeah not a lot is that you got it
it's hard to be upset they have a lot of
local humor like the comics from Hawaii
they I've seen some comics from Hawaii
they talked about local stuff mm-hmm you
know yeah I just like a cruise ship yes
like that well there yeah like the guys
the guys who are lived there they do
their whole act as local yeah and a lot
of times they like a morning DJ yeah
yeah you think about it that's a pretty
great life pretty [ __ ] great place if
you're a comic and in Hawai Jesus you
beat it you did it you really did first
time I went to why I was in Maui as
working at the some extend up book
through the ice house and I got off
stage and this guy comes up we're
talking and I said where you from he
goes I'm from Pittsburgh
I go really what did you do there he
goes I was uh I was a plumber I go what
do you do here now I go he goes I'm a
plumber I go how do you make it from a
plumber in Pittsburgh to Maui he goes
well one day I woke up and I realized I
could be a plumber in Hawaii or I could
be a plumber Pittsburgh wife makes all
the sense of the world it's all this is
the world
yeah if I was a plumber I'd moved there
yeah I know a guy who teaches jujitsu
there who used to teach in he actually
gave me my first lesson ever in Los
Angeles and he after a while he was like
[ __ ] this what am i doing
and I could teach him to Maui you know
and the thing about like a place like
Maui there's enough people like do you
need everything like it's not like like
Lanaya
we were talking about earlier yeah
that's a weird spot mm-hmm because
there's only 3,000 people in the whole
island it's like a good theater show
like a good theater show and those
people empty out that's the whole
civilization and then there's people
that fly in because it's a resort area
but it's uh I was in Kauai one time too
and it's similar like after I got off
stage I was like hey where can I go to
get something to eat there like there's
no there's no place to go this is in the
ocean catch it who does Laird Laird
Hamilton he lives in Kauai I don't know
Laird Hamilton that's the [ __ ] coffee
you're drinking bro this guy talked
about it for about a half hour early
I'm bad with names does that work is
that a good enough excuse I'm bad with
names Laird Hamilton's married to
Gabriella Reece that's the giant Aquaman
[ __ ] mm-hmm great coffee yeah he
makes killer car who thought to put to
America Kauai is a spot that I need to
get to I've never been to that one I've
never been to that Island I've only been
to Honolulu very briefly during a
layover you know when I was actually the
first time I was going on lanai
we flew in a Honolulu first and then you
have to take like a Puddle Jumper to get
to lanai oh yeah those lanai is like
there's nobody there around and you go
on the beach is like [ __ ] eight other
families on the beach everybody just
like everybody's just chill
I never sleep better oh my god I never I
mean when Iraq Singh I when I was in
Hawai I would go to bed at midnight I
wake up at 8:00 in the morning I'd slip
straight through it's never happened you
feel great ever yeah I come back to LA
I'm really getting headaches immediately
gets five like god damn it so I go go
get a drink and I order a mai tai
believe it or not Wilma Maui and Hawaii
in general I think they have some wonky
weed laws
I don't think weeds legal there no no
it's not it's it medical is I think
that's hilarious
yeah medical life is my condition I know
and what I needed for life yeah um but I
have so I didn't I have fans there so
they just give me some uh-huh do you
still do used to ever take pot from fans
unit braid yes yeah me too
yes just you're asking for it you are
right yeah oh I thought I'd give you a
little extra taste I put some acid out
of it for you I don't need that right my
good friend Ari Shaffir dosed Bert
Kreischer when they were doing a podcast
again so that's regal that's really
thought it was Joe knew he gave him
Molly dropped it in his drink so with
their hard feelings over oh yeah there
was a real problem so it was all a joke
oh there's no jokes with us we don't do
jokes I mean I just saw it on Twitter
yeah that's real oh that shit's real no
yeah so they're not pals on their back
okay the wife hates them still Oh Bert's
wife still ragged Verizon I would have a
hard time with that yeah I only tell
issue yeah I don't you know doing some
like that you that's not right that's
that's like 40 he knows he knows it's
not right what's really interesting is I
was we were just we were all joking
around about it like this is the only
business where you could dose your
friend we all joke around about it laugh
about it more nothing happens and he
actually got a bump in his career like
it starts selling out places faster and
when he was going places who you already
be doing shows and people would yell out
dose me re dose me so now he's known for
dosing people and before that are used
to do something I should say allegedly
because would this the this thing which
may or may not have happened is very
illegal but he would do a play in places
where weed was very legal he would play
a game called fine edible so he posted
on Twitter who give people hints and he
would leave some [ __ ] nuclear edible
like to some North Dakota guy who's
gonna find it who probably doesn't get
any real weed and he's gonna get one of
those stars of death and he got in
trouble I think in Minnesota oh really
allegedly cuz I don't think they ever
found any of the things he was talking
about so maybe it was all just a prank
let's go with that those edibles man my
brother has something one time he goes
it's Jimmy be careful it's called the
creeper that's what they call it and I'm
like I glad I have a high tolerance to
wear so I ate one and have like nothing
so I did the I did another one and about
45 minutes later we're at a campground
talking to my parents and all of a
sudden I can't remember how to breathe
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm so I just go I have to go make a
phone call I'm in a campground so I just
go to my car and I'm just laying down to
the next thing I know I hear my wife
behind me are you okay I go I'm not good
we have to go let's go say goodbye to
Brett I can't say goodbye let's just go
I couldn't deal with saying goodbye oh
my god
so yeah turns out there is some danger
to that metric oh well there's danger
with schizophrenia there's a real danger
with people having schizophrenic breaks
when they take high doses of edibles
really and even smoking it yeah well you
were like you were talking about well
you get that withdrawals yeah I don't
get it withdrawals but there's a small
percentage of people that do there's
small percentage yeah so that must be
like so people like all aren't you gonna
quit because know if you know if if I
stop that guy if I drop drinking coffee
when I went overseas I would get
headaches too right so it there's a lot
of things like that yeah coffee is one
thing that's addictive that we all just
admit it's just it and we just accept it
yeah we're addicted to it because it
doesn't really change your state that
much right were you like freaking out
like you never drink a cup of coffee
like me I can't get up you never on the
ground tweakin but I know a couple
people who have had legitimate
schizophrenic breaks okay you know a
couple mm-hmm yeah yeah legitimate ones
legitimate ones where like something
happened and then what is it we're never
the same again
what is literally yeah well I've heard
about that with acid but I never heard
about that with well it's not that much
difference when you take a high level
dose it can get cycles yeah yeah
different but you feel like you're
tripping yeah a little and you're
experiencing the God saved me from the
comments but people get mad at me when I
talk about this but there's a thing that
happens when you because I've talked
about it so many times and I know I'm a
repetitive [ __ ]
but even you eat marijuana your body
produces something called eleven hydroxy
metabolites
four to five times more psychoactive
than THC so as its processed by the
liver you get something that's not
psychoactive in the smoked form so when
you smoke it you get THC when you eat it
you get 11 hydroxy metabolites it's much
much stronger much stronger than THC
it's a totally different sensation you
know people talk about the body high
like yeah you feel it everywhere you
really tweak out - but but of small
leppe doses of that are wonderful like a
little like they have these Jambo has
the sprays oh I used to have one on the
desk but it's a THC spray just a couple
of pumps really yeah it's like a breath
spray a couple of pumps and it's like
God you feel great you feel really yeah
but if you take 12 pumps I took 12 pumps
once I did a podcast with Sam Harris and
them in the middle of I took the pumps
like 20 minutes before he got here and
then in the middle of the podcast I'm
like holy [ __ ] I don't know if I can
thank God
Sam is like a super articulate guy so I
could just kind of like throw a question
his way and he would just expend while
his expanding and talking I was
pretending listen but really just trying
to keep it together trying to keep it
together and and and make sure that I
tried to sober myself up I was like
trying to force myself into a state of
sobriety
it was about a thousand milligrams out
yeah I have a hard enough time paying
attention to conversations when I'm not
yeah when I'm completely sober I lose my
train of thought
me too and I'm like why did they or I'll
be sure if I'm bored right yeah not even
that even though if I'm super interested
I'm interviewing someone and all of a
sudden I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm not
listening I'm thinking about that thing
and then they stop talking and I'm like
huh oh you can't do that that's the
cardinal sin ah it's still good that's
one thing I don't think I do overlays at
least I don't
I can't remember I try to really lock in
its me too but then I just my mind will
just get oh so I was in interviewing
Tulsi and so this became to this
important part of the conversation it
was about how she had switched there's
something about her some policies she
had so I asked her about it and every I
know people are waiting
there was a documentary interion guy in
there with her and his phone went off at
that moment I asked the question but it
didn't go off like a ring it went off
like a scene from a movie so now I'm
like what is that who's talking and then
I was said I'm like what is good and
then after I realized that its disguised
fallen this is scene from a movie and
then that but tells he's been talking
this whole time
oh no so then I come back and she stops
sounds like you don't want someone else
in the room when having conversations no
no doubt what she was talking to a guy
and his girlfriend was sitting right
there and she just kept spinning in her
chair and I'm trying to pay attention
here but I'm just seeing this girl's
chair I'm playing with your phone and
then afterwards it was like no more no
more people in here because sometimes
people try to come in here and then
you'll see them like hold a camera up to
take a picture while the podcasts over
like a you're you're [ __ ] this thing
up man this is a distraction yeah like I
don't do live ones do you do you do live
ones live what live podcast yeah well
that's a different thing though because
you know you're gonna be live yeah this
isn't I mean live in front of a group of
human oh you mean with William in that
audience yeah but this is a lot either
oh so that's so that's not live we
stopped doing them live - no this isn't
live no there's a reason for that
oh that's good oh why what a head it's
on Mount know because because often the
other dad might show so like when we
were in the green room me Graham and Ron
will comb we're gonna do a show so we'll
say things funny to each other that you
can't say in public like South Park
right right and so we were saying in it
it's funny to us and then I was on the
show and with Ron and we were talking
about a gopher everyone and I almost
said it and I was like oh my god so you
know that you know yeah come South Park
gets away with that they're the best
because first of all it's cartoons they
don't even look remotely human and
they've been around for so long the
grandfathered in they go [ __ ] hard
there there's so important see the one
with the Harley Harley Davidson
motorcycle riders where they called them
all I don't even know if I can say it
they could say it what I'm talking about
they call them all the f-word the ends
and the T yeah
yes yes and and many more things like
that good it was played on TV like yes
they could play it on TV I can't say it
well do you remember a time there was a
time where they used to show those old
Roadrunner cartoons yes where they were
hyper violent yeah they were blowing
things up and hitting each other have
frying pans and shooting each other in
the face and it was okay
pushing my husband because it was old
and so the new cartoons were all
sanitized and nerfed up but the old ones
were still on but you would watch the
old ones go oh yeah this is what it used
to be like well I watched some old
Popeye the other day and Bluto is
basically a [ __ ] rapist yes thank you
yes a straight-up rapist just grabbing
olive oil like big fat face is crazy
she's trying to fight him off and papas
like hey let go of me girl yeah and he
has to punch her and or punch him yeah
he fights with Bluto and it's Bluto was
a rapist yeah he dragged her away that's
what that was somebody so [ __ ] it's
like a hundred years ago right so
basically a hundred years ago Popeye was
like nineteen thirty so almost 100 years
ago and humans were just living
different back then
I think rape was probably really
prevalent so prevalent that you could
joke around about it in a [ __ ]
cartoon yeah and so so you don't go
alive now because well a bunch of
channels started creating their own
channels with my clips and so this is
what can happen so if you have a channel
like and then someone says hey I'm gonna
take all your clips I'm gonna take the
interesting parts your podcast I'm gonna
make my own channel then they can get
like hundreds of thousands of
subscribers with all of your content
right and then they can have whatever
they want put that on this other than
they could use it as a white power
[ __ ] YouTube channel they're 500,000
subscribers they could use it as a men's
rights channel they can use it as you
know they could just switch it over and
say it's not about jimmy dore anymore
now it's about Bill burr and they'd just
use your content which is not legal and
I was like when they were doing it while
we were doing the show
so while we were doing the show they
were making clips and then uploading
them as we were lying you're still going
yes so they're doing it in real time so
okay I got it so now we realized that
those can be taken down and then we
started doing it ourselves and then we
realized like the only way to really
stop them from doing it in real time is
to do it like film it have the podcast
filmed and then have the clips cut up
and then release it okay oh okay that's
why okay that's a big one the other one
was copyright there's a real problem
with copyright strikes like if you get
three strikes they [ __ ] pull your
channel so do you ever go we've gotten
him we've got him before for [ __ ] that
we show we've got him for before for
[ __ ] that we show in the corner of the
screen like the corners feel like a
photograph or a video or a little tiny
thing the corner of the screen we had
one where we got one from a [ __ ] a
guy took a film from his like it was
like a cell phone of a satellite being
launched like the and we were watching
it let him watch the video we got a
copyright strike from that like just
watching something that we really
internet you can't do it you can't
people own these things the big one is
nature videos those [ __ ] nature
videos when you're seeing like a pack of
ya hyenas try to take out a lion if you
play that
that's a copyright strike they'll get
you for that so I had a copyright strike
recently a first one only one we've ever
had right that's a strike not like hey
we're gonna demonetized totally
different I get that all the time yeah
that's all the time but a strike is
serious because they can take your
channel down to more of them so the and
when they do that they have to put they
put a stamp you know time stamp of what
is the copy written audio right and
someone had put a copyright strike on it
at the end of every one of my videos it
goes dududududu and it's just from
itunes right it's not it's non royalty
thing it's just it's like a it's a chime
it's not even music right so it's from
GarageBand yes GarageBand right yeah and
so that's why LT 3 and so somebody put a
copyright strike on that and I'm like
that's just someone messing with me
that's just so a hater and some guy from
like Canada who's now living in like
I'll and we've had a guy track him down
and he's like yeah there's he has no
obvious source of revenue as he's
trolling you so he's saying that the guy
who investigated said he thinks it's
intelligence I'm like and so the reason
why he took that claim on that was the
show that he could take down every one
of my videos cuz that chimes and every
one of my videos so for a while I'd so
until that copyright strike got cleared
up I don't have a liaison it took a
while and so we took that chime out of
all our videos Christ yeah
yes so that's so I don't yeah YouTube is
weird but they're dealing with managing
an insane amount yeah I don't know mo
they can't and they always err on the
side of the copyright holder I get why
they do that they do it automatically
mm-hmm yeah I mean we've gotten
copyright hits for a screenshot you know
when you see the video and there's like
two heads and there's a small photograph
screenshot the screenshot was a photo
that someone that took and they were
claiming copyright on that photo that
was just on the Internet it's just
because we had it in our scan we had we
had to change the photo really yeah dude
it's [ __ ] I know and it's weird
because like some people like you have a
podcast that's just audio right so yeah
I have an audio and video and video some
people don't some people only have the
video and then that video goes away the
the you count on that YouTube
monetization like there's a lot of
people that did that they counted on
that YouTube money and then YouTube D
monetizes things just randomly like it
doesn't make any sense of podcast with
Tom Papa that were demonetized my fatty
stuff uh craziest thing he is like the
nicest roasts is like an offend no he's
not offensive he's hilarious he's a
sweetheart
yeah like Tom Papa like how many did
they deem on ties a Tom papa was like
two or three right
to the point where Papa gotten like
really paranoid and he was thinking he
thinks I want a new tube doesn't like me
there's something going on so yet he
wanted to contact some people at YouTube
and he went down this journey I remember
he had a he was hosting a pilot online
or like TBS or something and I got
called in to like do like a run-through
of it or whatever
and I remember I walked up to him and I
go hey Tom how do you get your own TV
show I really want to get one and he
goes here's what you do you have to
overextend yourself house you can't
afford desperate yeah and you got you
gotta make this happen
can you imagine going back to regular TV
now though with all the freedom that you
have no I can't no I can't I can't even
imagine going to the radio right I've
got in trouble I just got in trouble
right so I have to show it's on KPFK
they're all nice people but you can't
just cuz they're a non-profit there's
certain things you can't do like you
can't over endorse like I had a
candidate on and you're not supposed to
endorse and I can't you can't go hey go
to their website and donate you can't
say any of that stuff so yeah it's just
that I'm like oh so how'd you get in
trouble would you just so I did that
with who does so that guy Jen Cukor I
was running for that 25th - what the New
York Times did in him was dirty that was
didn't say the New York Times I just say
that writer whoever that writer was the
whole but there was a LA Times see it
was a unbelievable where York Times one
was the one with a job for ten years
that Duke where he was like oh of course
you're not racist it was as clear as day
that he was joking it's clear as day
that he was being sarcastic and so
talking to David [ __ ] Duke yeah the
Grand Wizard of the KKK and he's like oh
you're not racist of course you're not
racist and then they take that and put
it in quotes he said to David Duke of
course that's right so that's that's
like mr. Smith goes to Washington she's
dirty but I couldn't believe that was
the New York Times that hurt that one
hurt because I was like like you let you
think it's funny yeah like a New York
Times is horrible oh don't say that all
I've got left
you don't know
Joe you've got me got Kyle kolinsky oh
right Kyle yeah yeah hi I saw I saw your
interview with Kyle I love God I heard
we were talking yesterday he said this
[ __ ] you said good things about you
always I didn't get that part oh I could
after you told him he was your favorite
new show oh you're my number two I'll
take it
I think he's the most reasonable of all
the political commentators but you're a
comedian right and a political
commentator I think you have a dual
status specialist yeah and you're
funnier than him for sure oh that's feet
that's all i curve he texted me
yesterday New York City was 68 degrees
yes he was like what in the [ __ ] is
going on then he's like I feel bad
because I feel so happy
it's like seasonal depression you know
it's sunny out in 68 degrees like yeah
it's great
meanwhile the world's on fire yeah yeah
yeah whatever
it's warm it is warm yeah no he's great
there's that's the beautiful thing about
having corrupt and dishonest media is
that it opens a door for honest media
like you and independent guys like
yourself like pac-man
kolinsky it's easy this includes you
it's easy to outdo them and and MSNBC or
CNN or it really hurts hearing the the
freight from a guy respect the New York
Times is horrible that's always been
what I trusted he do I know it was it
was tough I was tough when I when I
realized that the mainstream news media
is just the mouthpiece for the
establishment when it really matters
therefore every war therefore every war
they're repeaters that how do we get
into Iraq they got jet Judas Miller to
uncritically put whatever Dick Cheney
told her on the front page that's why
they all day of aluminum tubes front
page of the New York Times and then Dick
Cheney so Dick Cheney tells Judith
Miller they they have aluminum tubes she
prints it on the front page of the New
York Times
Dick Cheney then goes on Meet the Press
and said look even the New York Times is
reporting this that's how they do it and
then Judith Miller gets it she gets an
on-air job and Fox News after that you
got rewarded there's that and then
there's probably also access to
candidates access to top official access
journalist you know if you don't give
them what they want they don't give you
access and this is sort of the game that
they've always played right that's
exactly right fact that they have access
and they they I've
I've experienced it but what do you
think why do you think they want a smear
jank I mean like because they see him as
an enemy of the Democratic Party because
he wants to get money out of politics
right so that's his big thing he has
Wolf Pack and his whole thing is I don't
take corporate money and that justice
Democrats they don't take corporate so
that's this whole thing right is about
getting money out of them politics and
they want to keep money in power because
if you give money out of politics their
whole grift is over right right then
you're not worth a hundred million
dollars anymore that's right how do you
go from zero to a hundred million
dollars as you're in Congress well
you're a criminal that's that's what
Truman said yeah there's there's the
only kind of people get rich while in
government are criminals that's what
Truman said but there's like isn't it
something like there's forms of insider
trading that are legal if you're in
Congress that wouldn't be legal if you
were a regular citizen I don't know I
know that they don't have them the rules
that they should write I know that
there's rules that I shouldn't say
regular citizen but if you were like
working for a corporation there's rules
like they're allowed to get information
and influence in terms of like how they
invest all right if that's not right
right that's that's extra information
that I could get exactly yeah that's
right extra and then they're allowed to
get that information and then they're
allowed to use it for their own personal
profit like somehow or another that's
not been stomped out yeah and that was
someone there was a video I don't know
if it's accurate or someone was
explaining how Nancy Pelosi made all
that money and I was like if I watch
this [ __ ] thing I'm gonna stay up all
night it was one of those like I can't
watch any more of this yeah well you
have a hundred millionaire is the leader
of the People's Party isn't that amazing
not only that like what did you do did
you sell hats or did you make that money
what do you do do you make cars why do
you think Nancy Pelosi impeached Trump I
did impeach George Bush I don't know
I'll tell you tell me as Julian Assange
revealed through WikiLeaks it was
because Nancy Pelosi was told in 2002
that our government was torturing people
and she was a present person in a
position of power and the reason why the
Republicans in George Bush
administration did that was so now
they've got Democrats complicit in their
crimes and so she didn't tell anybody
about it she didn't launched an
investigation she didn't blow the
whistle on this so now she's complicit
so what
George Bush Luke wants only Republicans
lose the house and she becomes leader
and they go you're gonna impeach him she
goes impeachment off the table and
nobody could figure it out but nobody
pushed her on it cuz we were just so
glad we had a check on George Bush at
that time well Julian Assange then
reveals there's a there's the memo that
shows that she was briefed in 2002 on
their torture program which makes her
complicit it towards her because she
didn't do a goddamn thing about it did
you see the interview that I did with
Edward Snowden oh yeah yeah yeah that's
not the first half it was very
interesting yeah Danny Pelosi came up oh
yeah he came up that she was one of the
people that cleared they made it so that
these cell phone companies have access
to your data and can can spy on you and
use it the government can use cell
phones and also all sorts of
telecommunications and essentially the
video your your voicemail emails all
that [ __ ] all that all that [ __ ] can can
get spied through and there was it was
very complicated like I don't I don't
remember the exact thing that that I
don't remember the exact scam like but
Pelosi was involved in that there you go
I mean they're all corrupt that's the
whole that's that that's kind of like
the mission of my show is to remind
people how we got Trump people want to
pretend that a corruption in lying
started in January 2017 the Afghanistan
papers just came out Joe that revealed
that three administration's in a row
lied completely 100% about Afghanistan
from the day they took over to the day
late left stuff like Donald Rumsfeld
saying we don't even know who the bad
guys are we have no idea who they are
well why are we there well it may be
because of the couple trillion dollars
in rare earth minerals I don't know how
they really think that maybe it's we
would go to war from minerals come on he
was crazy would try to steal somebody's
natural resources do we use upset at
what a small story it was I'm upset what
those papers came out and then no one
really even talked about and barely got
it nothing so ain't nothing it justifies
everything Tulsi Gabbard has been saying
these Wars I rely and [ __ ] and we
gotta get out of them and that that that
she's not the one lying about him the
one that's been lying about him
in our government including Barack Obama
that's what the Afghanistan papers prove
that they've been lot we've been lied to
her with the paper side some people so
what happened was they did a study just
like the Pentagon Papers right they do
their own study that reveals that
they're lying
so they interviewed four hundred people
that were like in the middle of generals
into the military and contractors and
all the kind of people to find out so
they can know what would happen in
Afghanistan so they revealed all this
the people who they were interviewing
revealed all this that at the beginning
of the board they didn't know who that
they still don't know who's the bad guys
who were killing they were lying about
they would lie that it's going well and
then their personal writings would be
revealing that they didn't know what the
hell they were doing and so it was it's
worse than you think but we can still
just keep sending four billion dollars a
month they're just keep sending it just
keep sending it for what no one knows
we're not leaving trumps didn't take us
out here it's gonna it's he's an up for
reelection a couple more months we're
still in Afghanistan he didn't do what
he said he was gonna do nobody does
that's the problem and that's why we got
Trump in the first place because it
comes in as an anti-war guy immediately
gets rolled by the military-industrial
complex just like Trump did I believe
that I I did believe that Trump his
druthers would get the hell out of the
middle east right but he doesn't really
have any druthers he was like okay I'm
done doing that cuz they rolled me hard
enough three years of Russia gate I'm
gonna do what they want well you saw the
conversation that he had with one
reporter we talked about the
military-industrial complex and about
how they want to go to war yes I mean
Trump looked actively while in office
this is like an Eisenhower thing like as
he's leaving while in office it's
talking about the military barely got
mentioned I know and so I so I think
that's why the establishment wants to
get rid of Trump even though he does
their bidding gives them their trillion
dollar tax cuts nobody asks how were
gonna pay for it he gives him he tries
to go into Venezuela he tried he tried
to do it you know he's doing Iran he
didn't come out we didn't get out of
Syria we're not out of Afghanistan keeps
sending more people back to Iraq it's
amazing what what's happened the exact
opposite of what he ran on is happening
so why do i why do i think this happens
it's because just what eisenhower said
is he left he says did we the undue
influence of the military
industrial complex and mention they just
invented 131 billion dollars more worth
of work for Raytheon and Boeing and
Halliburton how much money that's the
recording music business make a year I'm
80 Billy I mean how much does it we've
just invented a whole nother economy
just since Trump got an elected 131
extra billion let me just think what you
could do with that you could build 131
Yankee stadium's do you think every year
non-sena Klee do you think that a lot of
this impeachment stuff and a lot of the
scandal stuff is really a distraction
for a lot of these things they're
pushing through yes it's a hundred
percent distraction and just like I told
you because if they really believed that
he was doing all these things and he
wasn't why would they keep giving him
extra money to go bomb people that his
own because they they they don't try to
put handcuffs on him so that's how you
know they're full of [ __ ] and the reason
why they're coming at Trump in the way
there's there's waste so now they're
starting to oppose him because of this
Iran thing so now you turn on CNN and
Chris Cuomo goes hey why doesn't
Congress do its job and take back the
War Powers that they gave unto the
president under this a um so now which
is what I predicted what happened with
Trump the silver lining of a trump
presidency was all the [ __ ] that the
Democrats Republicans have been agreeing
on which is war fracking oping the
Arctic to drilling and all that stuff
gassing immigrants at the book now we're
all gonna become aware of it well the
Democrats spent three years doing
freaking Russia gate so they didn't ever
oppose him on that stuff and they let
him keep doing it and so now people are
starting to become aware of what's
happening and so now Chris Cuomo is
going hey why don't why don't we why
does it in Congress do their job why are
you letting crazy president Trump well
they just gave him a hundred and thirty
one but they they gave him his spying
powers again through the Patriot Act
they this guy who's working for Putin
you're gonna give him spying powers you
[ __ ] bullshitter they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] errs that's a weird scam yeah
Joe if you thought a guy was working for
Putin would you give him an extra
hundred thirty 1 billion dollars to go
bomb anybody at his own pay by the way
that's also intelligence is that a
rhetorical question yes so it so that's
why and you know people people give me a
hard time about support
tulsi right it's like why use but I
think it's really important to have an
anti-war voice that has you know speaks
from experience she's actually in the
military right now
she actually volunteered to go serve in
their illegal wars and then they smear
for it it's kind of amazing well she's a
weird one right because she has so many
characteristics that you would think
that everyone who is a progressive would
want as president she is a veteran who
twice served overseas took twice
deployed she's been a veteran for a long
time long time congresswoman she's from
Hawaii she's I mean I guess she's
Hawaiian you would say she's a woman of
color they say she's a woman of color
what color it's like she's Tanner than
me is she well she lives in Hawaii
that's why yeah I don't know about these
things I'm white I don't know it is
really I mean the Hawaiian roots are
essentially Polynesian and South Pacific
travelers who landed thousands of years
ago on those islands so yeah I mean it
is essentially a person of color either
way she's in a very articulate
rock-solid woman and they've tried to
find a bunch of dirt on her and they
can't and they and they don't know what
to do and it's just funny to me that a
lot of people who were supporting
Elizabeth Warren were [ __ ] on Tulsi
as hard as they can and of course
Elizabeth Warren shows her true colors
she she does a right wing sexist smear
on Bernie Sanders was that was weird
this is what a crazy fake smear like
nobody's buying that so it was it was
heard the media and the DNC got together
and they're like hey let's do this cuz
it was coordinated this didn't come out
of nowhere right and CN n to see that
story see it and wrote these to people
who heard it from these other two people
who were not even gonna name and that's
on CNN that's CNN that's how they do it
it's so great yes they're digging their
own grave though what they're what
they're doing is they're making
themselves less and less relevant and
they're making guys like you and
independent people more and more
relevant and more and more trustworthy
and that's why they keep going to the
catnip of Russia gate or Joe's tweets or
whatever at Pietschmann and this phone
call to the thing and you know look how
they look how the media runs
interference for the establishment it's
amazing like you know to pretend that
the Biden's aren't corrupt I know this
and to have people come on and go that's
a
that's no corruption it's been looked
into there's no corruption that a guy
has an $83,000 job on a board in a
country his dad just helped overthrow
what are you [ __ ] crazy it seems like
it might be a little corrupt well the
conversation where he tells the
prosecutor that if he's not gone you
don't get the billion dollars right what
do you know they fired the guy right saw
that video so yeah I've saw that video
and did but the defense to that is
they're saying but that prosecutor was
corrupt and the next guy was even more
tougher of an investigator but that guy
was investigating verismo at the time
yeah and that guy it did say later that
guy who got fired said I got fired
because I was investigating BER is mo he
said that in a court document so believe
me they're all Crider why didn't they
why didn't they impeach Trump on the
emoluments clause why didn't they do
that why did they do it on the lawn so
that's him benefiting off his position
in government it's because they all do
it why do you think because it would
bring up everything you would have to
that's right hey Hillary Clinton I mean
Chelsea Clinton's got a nine million
dollar job for she deserves oh my god
she did she did the best so then people
are saying that people are saying what's
wrong with the woman using her degree
she has three degrees I wonder how she
was at for able to afford those three
degrees I wonder she overcame all those
obstacles did she did yeah so if they're
all corrupt that's that's then that's
the story and that's why we had Donald
Trump clinging to this system that's why
we don't have a functioning medical
system or a functioning banking system
because Barack Obama was paid off by the
bay by the health insurance companies
and the Wall Street banks and that's not
me saying that that's Dylan Ratigan an
award-winning Bloomberg reporter says
that how'd they pay him off uh well he
has a I don't know if he noticed he just
bought a house at Martha's Vineyard from
the guy who owns the Celtics he says yes
forty has 49 acres he's got a lot of
money forty-nine that's more acres than
Kevin Hart wow that's a lot of acres
yeah that's that's the guy who's a
community organizer I guess it was a
gated community
[Music]
but how did they pay money how does that
work here how's that work where it's
legal like how does how does the the
president get pushy when he left tot
when he left the presidency he goes
windsurfing with Branson for a while
right as we still don't have clean water
and Flint and and then when he comes
back in the public life the first thing
he does he goes to make speeches for
equity firms we had a half a million a
pop yeah for 20 minutes Pete what do you
think that is what do you think all this
is this is a bribe
what are you after the fact yes yeah but
it's amazing that they still honor that
that they're so rock solid in their
commitment to this corrupt system that
even after the guy can't even help him
anymore he's out of office they hook him
up with these speaking jobs right he
gets a half a million bucks a pop and
then whatever he wants to do yeah was
another thing about the Clinton
Foundation where Bill Clinton would he
would make sure that he got speaking
gigs along with that weapons deals that
she was giving yes yeah this is correct
yeah everybody's again they're dirty we
didn't get Trump because the Democratic
Party was doing their job right their
people were got desperate and decided to
take a chance on a political novice game
show host who they knew was a
bullshitter
everybody knows Trump's a bullshitter
they were that good go [ __ ] those
people we hate yeah and that's deceit
and iíve been imploring the Bernie
campaign which nobody listens to me so
it doesn't matter why don't they listen
to you I don't know maybe because I
communicate in a caustic way Joe but I
I've been trying to burnish is should be
wiping the floor with these candidates
he that shouldn't even be close right
Minh so I've been employing them
Bernie take the gloves off would you
quit turning to Joe Biden and saying my
best friend Joe Biden you got to do what
Trump did what Trump was running he ran
against the Republican Party he ran
against all those pukes that the people
are sick and tired of that the people
have been let down by these are the
people who took you to Iraq these are
the people who took you to Libya these
are the people who are bankrupting you
these are the people so that's what he
did and and you know Bernie gets up and
he goes drove my good friend I just want
you know you're corrupt
it's like quit saying you're friends
with these [ __ ] guys to work erupt
quit do just what he could land it he
should turn and I've been begging he
came close in the last debate he kind of
killed it in his voice
tell I'm not good at impressed he's my
good friends the best buddy got right
there that was a pound one Joe Biden the
reason why you can't understand how a
medicare-for-all works is because you're
corrupt and you're paid not to
understand and we're gonna get rid of
your brand of corruption when I'm
president cuz you're the problem
oh my god people would go crazy the
place would go [ __ ] crazy and
Elizabeth Warren would stand up for Joe
Biden that's all I'm a sexist piece
right and everybody would see what the
game is wasn't he like always in the
name of Elizabeth Biden yeah Elizabeth
Biden Elizabeth Warren wasn't he always
in support of her Joe Biden yeah
no no no no Bernie Sanders yeah II was
always in support yes
so Elizabeth Warren and was like hey
Bernie's policies are pretty popular
I'll pretend like they're mine yeah well
she's a Republican people forget until
she was 47 years old Yeah right forget
that yeah well Burt while Bernie was
running around telling people that a
woman could be President she was still a
Republican yes
FYI yeah so it's amazing that you know
it's like is anybody gonna vote for
Elizabeth Warren over Bernie it's like
vaping that's what I say it's like just
smoke the real thing right well there's
a lot of people that still just want a
woman president that's right yeah and I
understand I understand that but you you
got you can't let identity trump policy
you got a you you know that's what
identity politics well we're gonna have
a woman who's not as good as a guy or
and we'll have a woman who could be it's
like no you're supposed to marry them
together you know you can't just just
because of her identity that's not good
he's gonna torture her if she makes it
if she becomes the nominee she felt
honest [ __ ] she's handle Meghan McCain
the other day on the view did you see
that I'm Meghan McCain twisted into a
pretzel the get her to say Soleimani was
a terrorist it was unbelievable the way
she did this really why don't you say he
is terrorist though what what and then
she doesn't do what puff your cheeks are
no the fighter you get away with [ __ ]
what do you mean what did I do
I don't know I'm just saying it said
puff your cheeks out
from are we supposed to pretend she's
not fat
whoo-hoo we're talking about who we
talking about the ever seen Tim Dylan do
his version of Megan McCain no oh I'm
gonna get you something beautiful right
now
oh really gonna show you something
amazing so there's this tape somebody
put together about Megan McCain saying
my father have you seen that one where
she says it over and over
so I started I was in Ventura California
is playing that clip like as a joke like
it we're all gonna laugh there's almost
a [ __ ] riot at my show people made me
stop playing it they didn't want to see
it at first I thought they were like
cheering cuz they cheer often at my show
and then I'm like oh no they're
screaming of interest sketchies ahead
Ventura is like why you know it's one of
them Torrance places like witty it's
doing here watch this play from the
beginning and give me some volume okay
play hit less privately to be the
greatest politician that has ever lived
my name is Megan McCain and I'm on a new
show called the view and Donald Trump
that [ __ ] riverboat casino captain is
talking [ __ ] about my father again my
father was tortured for a hundred years
for this [ __ ] country and he came
back and he started seven wars because
he's a gentleman my father's skin mask
and I'm gonna primary Trump from the
view he's the best that impression
[Laughter]
animal Wow who is that Tim Dylan oh
that's funny whose comic is New York
guys out here now ah that's funny
Oh arias don't you love being a comedian
I love it I love guys like him that to
me is that's there's not a [ __ ]
filter to be found not a filter to be
found
oh yeah yeah and he's gay yeah so he's
got like a free pass to get wild when
you're gay you can get away with more
[ __ ] you know don't you say more thing
which I was you could say crazy [ __ ]
about women he went around as Jeffery
Epstein's temple temple which by the way
that temple is [ __ ] how strange is
that that it's the same colors as
Israeli flag Jesus crowd yeah yeah yeah
it looks like these really flag okay
yeah what who's that Chuck Schumer
walking away from like Chuck Schumer
yeah oh wow that was funny thanks for
puzzle areas he does a lot of [ __ ] he he
he works like he puts in a lot of time
he does a lot of things a lot of content
oh yeah got a lot of [ __ ] yeah and he's
a really funny comic too I gotta do more
comedy so what's been going on you
haven't been doing a lot I go out but
it's like I don't drive as far as I
should are you do you go to the store I
get it you know what I've never worked
at the store how dare you I did actually
send an email I go hey I want to do my
show down at the store in La Jolla yeah
cuz I want to go to San Diego again do
you oh that Club is one of the greatest
clubs in the world
it's like store down there that store
down there is perfect it's perfect it's
like a perfect comedy club I sent an
email I didn't get in return
oh well they're probably booked it's so
booked every blow that you know the
store has never been more popular right
now it's sold out every night yeah I
know I did yeah I should start going
there I just gotta get out my ass I just
gotta get off my go to you know I go to
flappers which is in Burbank so it's
real close to my house and I go up I go
up there a couple times a week and it
feels good then I go to the comedy magic
club on the weekend it's good club
that's a great I love in there and I go
to the improv randomly yeah and so
that's that's pretty much my how often
you getting up a week just
maybe you know two or three times well
that's not too bad it's not you buy it's
not good yeah I'm doing three sets
tonight see that's what I'm talking
about yeah do a lot of reps about reps
all about reps it's like Alan hate my
out my friend Allan Havey goes to New
York and now he who works at that um the
Comedy Cellar and they have like three
venues now so he just has to make one
call and he gets three sets a night if I
could just go out and need to have to
travel far it's like all real close yeah
that's yeah that's there's nothing
better than doing three sets a night
right well stand-up is like I feel like
it's like running like you want runners
endurance you want to be in shape you
got to run you have to run and stand up
you have to do stand-up you do it you
get into it you get the rhythm you get
the groove you feel you feel it once you
start thinking over thinking it yeah and
that happens with you know if you have
too much of a break for me anyway
I start to overthink it I starts to get
nervous yeah of corner vez oh yeah if
you take time off I was take you feel
uncomfortable that's the best way to
describe it's not absolutely nervous cuz
I know
jokes I know how to tell him right but I
don't feel comfortable right yeah it's a
totally yes I was in um so just in
Portland this last weekend did helium up
there no I do the Alberta Rose Theatre
and I had to write a whole new show cuz
we came back too soon like six months
ago we were inside to write a whole new
[ __ ] show and I was really sweating
it I didn't realize how how nervous I
was you know like I and so when I got on
stage like about thirty minutes in it
was going good
right I got my appetite all of a sudden
I was hungry and so I got a calzone I
had to eat it on stage yes
what I was starving I had another two
hours ago my show goes two and a half
hours and sometimes eight while you're
on some might sound like I have to get
yeah right it's got a calzone handle it
they all went and got calzones
they sold out so you had a break no we
just sighs I'm doing the show I have I
had three people up on stage with me I
had you in the calzone business are you
the Nancy Pelosi of Callan's
I how's that what's going on you know I
have I have some interests in calzone
know how you can do that that's I I've
often looked I'll be on stage and I look
down and chicken wing I'm like I could
eat that [ __ ] thing right now
really I get ya so as soon as my
nervousness goes away like I'll get
hungry yeah that's so weird yeah while
you're on stage you get hungry if I'm
yeah cuz my nervousness goes away oh no
I understand
so before that because of the
nervousness you can't eat yeah
so you go onstage hungry yes but you
probably should be but I don't feel
hungry when I go out say this I feel
like a naught or whatever and then the
nervousness goes away everyone well yeah
I got a [ __ ] to eat something
mm-hmm you go onstage and you do two and
a half hours yeah whoa yeah a lot of
time well let's not stand up I'm now I
have video that's right you're doing
your [ __ ] video time doing a video show
yeah so but we write jokes for the
videos and everything it's not just guys
doing a podcast right that makes a
little more sense that you want to eat
in the middle of it yeah a little more
sense cuz I look if you're on stage
doing your ass oh yeah you can't if I'm
doing my act that's why I say I often
doing my act I've looked like I'd like
to have a piece of that chicken you
can't do that like I could play a video
that's gonna be a minute like oh so
that's what you need to come back yeah
do you worry about [ __ ] flying out of
your mouth were you talking I do not
worry about that because if people
already like me okay that's good yeah
that you know it's such a freeing such I
don't have to convince anybody or and
that's the weird thing with my kind of
calm like I like to go up in front of
people who don't know me to Surprise
them and it's in a way like watch I'm
gonna but I also have to get into it a
little gentler yeah gently I don't get
more gentle yeah so I have to get into I
have to act like hey my brother said
this you know or hey why did I'm stood
um I don't get it you know like why why
is the government against workers
strikes but they're for a military
strike you know as opposed to the way
you would do it in front of your crowd
yeah yeah in front of my crowd up much
more you know amped up and angry or what
have you that make sense yeah yeah it's
a weird thing right there's a catch-22
to that cuz like if you play to your
people all the time you can get soft cuz
they'll laugh at stuff just because they
like you that's right and then a regular
audience be like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that's right
there's some people that I've seen where
they do well especially like some
podcast folks they have a crowd and then
the people will come to see them when
they do their shows and like oh they're
just happy to see you in you
well but then you go do a show a Rando
show on the [ __ ] improv was like five
other people especially that lab that
lab is hot deaf at the improv yeah that
little tiny room it can be it's set up
all [ __ ] up the doors right next to
your stage you're on stage and you hear
the door and see people walking in the
bar is enormous it's way too big it's
like if if everyone in the room was a
rabid alcoholic maybe you could justify
having a bar that big in a room that
small then that's funny better you know
but now that you mentioned I'm I guess I
noticed that stuff but did you like that
room on fire
this really should take sage through
that room I injured of ghosts in the way
not far I enjoyed it because there's no
waitresses right not that I don't like
waitresses you go put it your Ostrom go
get you if you want to drink you go to
the bar oh so nobody walks around in
front of you with this so it's indoors
no distractions people just sit there
all your anti waitress a male bartender
a rugged you know we just got done
making fun about Kyle kolinsky got in
trouble for making fun of Elizabeth
Warren's dancing he didn't get in
trouble that Booker guy went out like
that is nonsense you virtual signaling
dummy that is so silly
if he made fun of everything he made fun
of cory booker's Jos dad Joe made fun of
the thing that's that but if he makes
fun of Elizabeth Warren all of a sudden
that sex is that this is his quote well
you see what he said it like it was so
clunky like I'm sorry you had 18
year-old autistic college students get
to talk for the first time yeah yeah yes
so clunky yeah how did you formulate
this this sentence did you really feel
this then and who do you thinks gonna
believe this what is the people who are
gonna believe this what you would they
already like you the most of the people
are gonna see right through this thing
so it was just to me it's like you know
it's a schizophrenic message from people
like that Lisbeth Warren's defenders
it's like well women can women can do
anything except take a joke
I guess dance
you're dense let's watch that video
Elizabeth Warren desi if you're not
making fun of that you're out of your
[ __ ] mind if there's a thing to make
fun of why do white people think this is
dancing by the way you ever noticed that
George Bush dance move and then then she
does this to undo that
I think Ellen maybe may do that I don't
know
Elon must do to de Cielo Neal uncle
China I took his jacket off threw it on
the ground was dancing it's having a
good time I guess that's okay I gotta
cuz that pops yeah he's not running for
anything exactly yeah and everybody made
fun of it nobody accused anybody being
sexist really yeah dancing was hilarious
we'll play that first well played that
second let's play the Elizabeth Warren
one first because it Elizabeth Warren
one it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
you're watching her dance and you're
like how how dare you say I can't make
fun of this how dare you how dare you
fine obviously it's by the way it's not
like somebody put up a cell phone video
of her dancing at a wedding no one's
gonna get make know was that's okay
you're gonna she's on stage trying to
get something from people and she thinks
this will get it for ya here we go
here she goes oh here she goes here
she's up there I don't know if you can
play that music so she decided yeah we
can't play that music so it's uh we're
gonna dancing so first of all this isn't
that no there's no one with Julian
Castro is in the background this is a
different one this is her oh there she
goes though oh no she did there do ya oh
no that would know she keeps doing this
if she looks like her back is welded
like I saw what yes you're right
she's barely real it's about being white
mmm you know those weird because I
thought she's Native American well
that's what I said you know but so
obviously Bernie's lying about saying
women can't win or Elizabeth Warren is
lying about him saying that and I'm not
gonna accuse a Native American of lying
I'm just not gonna go good for you
she is one one-thousandth Native
American so that's that's real that's a
real number so it might be mm she's 70
that hot her moves shouldn't be like
very last
right that's a lot of 70 year olds that
are not there good point 70 she actually
looks pretty good for 70 because bernie
looks like [ __ ] right
Bernie head is in the middle of his
chest it's like it's like falling on if
I was his friend I'd be like bro you got
to work on your posture we gotta get you
some spinal decompression okay do some
yoga classes you're gonna your head's
gonna fall when you meet him he's taller
than you think right that's right for
you yeah you meet him like oh I thought
it's supposed to be up here I thought
for sure I was gonna be taller than him
when I met him you ever have that happen
I thought for sure I'm gonna be too or
uh any any was he's way taller than me
well I'm 5/8 I always assume I'm shorter
than everybody meet him okay pretty much
so uh unless they like a tiny person I
thought Chris Hedges was gonna be six
five when I met him and he's saying like
he's a normal guy yeah it's normal that
tall if you met Chris Cuomo afraid Oh
Fred you call afraid oh no he'll read my
[ __ ] if I do he'll wreck your [ __ ] and
throw me down some stairs
that was so revealing who are you are
you 16 but you know that Fredo is the N
word for oh we've all said we've all
said we've been saying that for years
get fed it fettuccine L N word
that is so [ __ ] dumb and say that the
idea that he thought that he could pass
it off and he knew they were filming
right yes yeah how do you not so it's
like Colin saying that to an
italian-american is like using the
n-word like oh is it really
guess what here's the thing about being
Italian there's no word for us there's
no word for us you can call me a Guinea
you can call me a [ __ ] it's like
okay doesn't work whereas no word they
don't work they work for my
grandfather's day I used to talk to my
grandfather because you know he was an
immigrant and he came over from Italy
and he told me all the horrible [ __ ]
kids in school would say to him all the
horrible [ __ ] people history yeah
guineas back then were they were they
were talked to like trash immigrants
like they were they wanted them to go
home they didn't want him there and
there was a lot of dispute between the
Irish and the Italian yeah once were
thought of the way a lot of racist
people think of Mexicans like they're
coming over here to take our jobs
coming up they're investing our
neighborhood with their smells and their
food in there they want to talk their
language like my grandparents always
spoke Italian in the house always they
smell great depends what you like I love
Italian food so it smells great but they
always talked Italian my grandmother and
my grandfather always spoke at town each
other yeah
they lived in an Italian neighborhood up
until it changed they lived in Newark
New Jersey okay which was all town so it
seems like every wave of immigrants
becomes the new horrible person right so
I grew up because when I was Irish and
they talk about how the no Irish need
apply all that stuff and then you know I
mean that's what it's just there's waves
of this right and now the wave is you
know Mexicans the scapegoats but you
know there's that documentary they did a
while back a day with no Mexicans uh-huh
but it's true everything would [ __ ]
shot down especially Los Angeles no
kidding but most of the country most of
the country this is the dirty secret
about the United States of America is
that we rely a lot of it shouldn't say
we a lot of industry podcasters doesn't
really rely on illegal immigrants but a
lot of industries rely on illegal
immigrants and it's it's a [ __ ] up
situation to be in for them because they
really don't have a path to become legal
even if they've been proven right for
decade after decade that they're a
viable contributing part of our culture
because they got over here illegally
even if they came over here as a child
that we can't we can't let you stay you
know and that's another thing you know
the immigration had they've been
scapegoated since as far as I can
remember Bill Clinton so Bill Clinton if
you go back there c-span videos of him
saying Mexicans coming here taking our
jobs and all that stuff used he did all
that stuff and Hillary Clinton she
bragged that she voted for a border wall
so our barrier was a fence in some
places about she bragged used to brag
about it
and so then Trump comes along and turns
it up another notch and they're like
this guy's [ __ ] yeah it's like no you
guys went so I make this point he just
says it in a way this yeah it's very
offensive and it's wrong right when he
of course it is but what I'm saying is
he's building off of a bunch of [ __ ]
that defense have been wrong just like
when they tweeted out those so you find
out
this is what I say oh he banned all the
Muslims at the airport then you find out
why are they at the airport brocco bomb
has been bombing them for eight [ __ ]
years Street
he dropped 26 thousand but they ran out
of Bob's then you find out he's putting
immigrants in cages you find out about
Barack Obama built those cages then you
say find out that Trump is gassing
immigrants at the border and you find
out Barack Obama also guessed immigrants
at the border and they should be honored
they were gassed by the lesser of two
evils so there is the silver lining and
it's finally starting to come out
because the Democrats have run this
Russia gate too that it's done they did
the mullet report it's over he concluded
there is no collusion it's over so now
they moved on to impeachment but now
he's bombing so they're finally starting
to talk about the War Powers Act they're
finally talking but nobody's talking
about cutting the Pentagon budget did
you hear do you hear that I don't hear
no do you think the the main the main
thing about impeachment is supposedly
that he tried to get Ukraine to
investigate his political parade Joe
Biden right that's the main thing that's
what they say take that out and there's
basically nothing right and and and
people aren't really that upset that he
tried to half the country for sure
aren't upset that he tried to
investigate so many people are clinging
to this as if this is a repeater makes
sense because they think that he's not
presidential that's it yeah that as
aaron Mattei says who's the only guy I
know who won an award for his Russia
gate coverage because he debunked it
like a good report is supposed to do but
he he always makes the point that Trump
is not a suitable steward of imperialism
and they think he puts an ugly face on
the [ __ ] we've been this is what I've
this is the Trump puts an ugly face on
the stuff we've been doing all along and
so now people are gonna be more aware of
it and we would have been more aware of
it if the Democrats would have actually
opposed him on substance instead of
Russia gay he says things sometimes ego
you are just allowed to write your own
speech like we knew when he was talking
about Baghdadi that he died like a dog
senior like what you're allowed to say
that he died like a dog or how about
that this is the weird thing that he
uses Twitter to threaten other countries
like when he was talking about Iran that
if they respond they will respond in
perhaps a disproportionate manner
mmm-hmm like you're using Twitter mm-hmm
to threaten like nobody ever thought
that there was gonna be this sort of a
venue for a president to just just have
mouth diarrhea mm-hmm
and that's why they I mean I really
believe that's a big reason why a lot of
the establishment wants to get rid of
him because he makes them look bad
because they agree with his policies the
Democrats just gave him everything he
wanted they paid for his [ __ ] border
wall
they gave him expanded spying powers
they gave him my extra 131 billion to go
bomb people they helped fast-track as
judges they [ __ ] also helped him
deregulate Wall Street what the [ __ ]
aren't they doing for him and that's why
we have Donald Trump and that's why it's
important that Bernie gets in that's why
it's important that he overcomes their
cheating and I just want Bert you talk
about schizophrenic like Bernie has a
schizophrenic strategy like people are
upset that I critique his strategy I
want pretty to be stronger I want him to
win and I want him to so like he could
come on give a speech where he says I'm
running against the Democratic
establishment and people go crazy right
because we know that's the problem
and then he'll do a video where he
endorses the DNC like hey give us money
we got he listed a video with all the
Democratic candidates talking about
unity and you ate every campaign had to
pay 170 thousand dollars to the DNC to
be included in that video why because
the DNC is bankrupt why because no one's
donating to it and so they have to
extort money out of their own candidates
saying if you don't give us 170 thousand
dollars each to do this unity video we
won't have any money to help you once
you win the nomination so they all
pointed up and they're all in it and
Bernie's in a unity video where he's
supposed to be speaking against
millionaires and billionaires there's
two billionaires in the [ __ ] video
Tom Steyer and Bloomberg we got to come
together with boo billionaires to oppose
no they are the [ __ ] problem is the
problem he's not he's the guy who
instituted stop and frisk he's the guy
who says New York needs more
billionaires those are the [ __ ] guys
who are the problem and if Bernie would
just get stopped you know playing
footsie with them in a sense you know
and just bash them I think it wouldn't
even be close they would say he's got
like Barack Obama he's got to over win
because they're gonna cheat him so he
has to over win
you know and I tell you what if he
picked of tulsi gabbard as his vice
president he would crush Donald Trump
because there are a lot of right-wingers
and there's a lot of independents
there's a lot of anti-war people who are
upset with the Republican Party a lot of
independents libertarians were set and
they like her because she's a and all
the things that you like about her she's
young she doesn't fly off the hip and
she's proven herself as a patriot all
that stuff what do you think they're
doing who do you think they're leaning
towards for the nominee do you think
they want Warren
oh the establishment yes yeah the devil
that's why the DNC the media and
Elizabeth Warren's campaign coordinated
on this latest sexist hit on Bernie
Sanders but it's not working I don't
think so
I think it's backfiring it's it should
backfire it's just it's amazing that the
the Pocahontas stuff that she's gotten
as far as she has is with lying about
being Native American and using it to
get a job and the way she lies about it
but she's such a bet again she's also a
bad liar like when Megan McCain can
twist you at a pretzel that's not good
you know when you cheat she went on some
podcast with these black guys I don't
even ever see that video where she's
being interviewed by three black guys
and this broad yeah they just tear her
to shreds was that Charlemagne is that
on The Breakfast Club I think maybe I
don't know you don't know anything
Charlemagne sharp as [ __ ]
I think he went after her for the whole
native yeah thing and she was just
basically saying well it's a family
worry that we he nailed it was it was
easy you know it was like you got you
talking to Barry Weiss questions Karen
what is a toady mean Charlamagne tha God
calls Elizabeth Warren the original
Rachel Dolezal that's right yes that's
right yeah that's what he did yes yes
yes yeah yeah that is that's a hilarious
thing to say the original originals
though well she used it to get a job I
mean she really did and she didn't give
any of that money back I mean didn't she
get a job at Harvard because of that she
claimed she did it she claims she did
but it was on her application yeah she
was Native American reason why yeah and
she's just saying this because our
family but she was saying she's Native
American like that's the whole thing
you're a heart a hundred percent that I
don't know what she was right I know
it's it's really come back to bite her
in the ass
no huh not enough she still bouncing
around I think that's how lier like
she's a she's a person that makes up a
past she's created a fake pass and she
did it back when there was no DNA test
available so you can get away with being
Native American it makes you look like
you're well first of all you're kind of
cool right everybody like never see that
movie Vision Quest no great movies
Matthew Modine his buddies like fake
Indian his buddy lied about being Native
American he had a mohawk and everything
he was playing up the Native American
thing because people want to be Native
American it's a cool thing yeah you know
that they're they've thought to be more
spiritual more deep and interesting and
and it's certainly more oppressed so if
you say that if she says she's Native
American oh look at this Native American
woman who made it all the way to be
President it's exactly yeah meanwhile
she's like what like 1 mm Native
American is that what it was some
ridiculous ridiculously small numbers
right so suggestion when she got her DNA
test Trump said that you if she was
Native American that he would give a
million dollars to charity give her a
million dollars some of that and since
she was like well time to pay up like
what did you look at the numbers yes she
did yes she did Joe like that everything
you're saying right now is sexist I hope
you know that [ __ ] yeah everything
you're saying is saying mmm must be
right I'm talking about a woman what do
people you know what I you know you talk
about how you feel bad about the New
York Times that being yes because I know
I know that feeling you wanted somebody
to be what what are the other news
people like at MSNBC and see what did
they think when they see Tucker Carlson
kicking their ass doing war coverage
isn't that [ __ ] amazing the tucker
carlson thing was interesting right
amazing he seems at least partially
independent like hawai is he allowed to
tell the truth about war at foxnews i
don't [ __ ] get that they're not
allowed to tell the truth about war at
CNN or MSNBC well shepard smith was
allowed to tell the truth to but he's so
sorry truth but he was against her why i
really the [ __ ] out of here
yeah again there's lots of truths he
didn't tell also so that's why
did you see bombshell no what is this
that's the movie with the Roger Ailes
movie oh I started watching that oh man
that guy who's the actor that from
Australia what's his name
Oh whoever that guy is he's fantastic
in balm what business that John Lithgow
and bombshell though if you're thinking
of the Dick Cheney movie I'm thinking of
a series there's a series about Roger
Ailes and Fox News oh and now this is a
movie
Haydn's this is a new Charlize at all oh
really yeah well she plays megyn kelly
oh really yeah yeah so she ain't playing
someone else attractive ni WRC is a
nonprofit working to protect Native
women from violence more than half of
Native women have experienced sexual
violence and the majority of violent
crimes against Native Americans are
perpetrated by non natives send them
your 1 million dollar check real Donald
Trump so she's saying that because she's
Native American she tested like a trace
amount like it really it's probably like
she blew a Native American guy in
college well when it is by the way real
Donald Trump
I remember saying on 7/5 you give me 1
million dollars for charity if I choice
my DNA showed Native American ancestry I
remember and here's the verdict Warren
tests were worn reveals test confirming
ancestry yeah but it's such an insanely
small amount uh-huh god I am 1.6 percent
African I am 200 times more like a
Native American that's real yeah l-o-l
so imagine I mean I thought that when
she said she got fired from teaching and
then the video came out said she quit I
thought that would be the end that
should be the end too I got called from
talking about that oh you are successful
I had a Clinton advisor come at me a
Bill Clinton advisor hmm that's
hilarious the advisers should all shut
the fueling up you would think you were
so lucky you're not in jail you only
flew 26 times with Jeffrey Epstein it's
not a lot of times he was a good guy he
had a nice jet we flew around we saw the
sky
things we had a couple drinks you do a
good Clint it's all right it's not that
good Jeffrey Jeffrey actually does a
good clan but that's because he's got
hours and hours and hours of tapes on me
am I trying to do an impression it
sounds like a drunk Irish no you're
Bernie's pretty damn good
but bill is so obvious $27 yeah there it
is you know why $27 cuz that's my social
security number 27 that's good yeah he's
cuz he was the 27th personal life I told
joke Joe yeah it was funnier in 2016 I
get it okay but any Bill Clinton adviser
calling you a sexist yeah that is it
that's right
damned hilarious that's rich did you
write to come off your dress before you
called me a sexist that [ __ ] guy goof
when he dies there will be stories yeah
well there's already stories it was just
we just haven't heard them oh yeah yeah
but I mean it's just it's amazing how
much they can keep quiet well it's
amazing that the Epstein thing just
comes and goes and nobody gets nobody
nobody gets thrown running out of office
nobody gets nothing nothing [ __ ]
nothing well how about the fact that
they accidentally erased the first
attempted suicide video whoops
we accidentally erased that too how
about they erased all the torture videos
I mean they did that too CIA did that
they lie to Congress on camera they did
its Joe we're living in it happens yeah
things go bad what does jesse ventura
say he says uh when yeah telling the
truth is if I couldn't forget that quote
but when you're living in the universal
deceit telling the truth is a treasonous
actress mm and I just said it earlier Oh
Jesse Ventura yeah he was gonna run for
president wasn't he he as an independent
I don't know yeah I think he toyed with
it his bloomberg's don't right yes he is
yes I don't hear anything about he's
spending tons of money on ads and stuff
and so is uh Steyr steyr they say was
like number two and he got himself up to
like number two in South Carolina or
something because of all the money he's
spending and you talked to people who
lived there they guy went home for
Christmas and every third commercial was
a Tom Steyer commercial so it's a local
thing market yeah so he's like
okay I might not win Iowa but I can
maybe put all my money into South
Carolina so do you think the
establishment wants to Lizabeth Warren
cuz she's because of the fact look she's
willing to play ball yeah she wants to
be president yes
she was a Republican forever and then
she switched over became a Democrat this
thing about him
Bernie being sexist is so obviously a
political ploy it's so transparent and
really gross yeah so now when someone
acts so now when they call Trump a
sexist it doesn't land right exactly the
cried wolf to me that's exactly what I
mean
you at they teach this to six-year-olds
don't cry wolf and here they are an
entire organization that's the
establishment has been crying wolf
it's crazies [ __ ] these
[ __ ] what do you keep looking
at your shirt for I spilled that did you
notice that see how I'm noticed I'm
observant I am so huh so how many times
you go out in a week how many times I do
shows yeah stand up it depends on the
week but always at least for this week
I'm only working Tuesday and Wednesday
night because I've got to go and do the
UFC this weekend in Vegas and I didn't
schedule a gig and but a regular weekend
boy depending on from on the road or
here if I'm here I mean on a regular
week I work Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday I do that all the time
I'll do multiple sets a night I'll do
the store I'll do the improv you like to
do the ice house okay so I change
subjects real quick do you watch boxing
yes
did you watch fries yes what whoo you
got fat he was party why did he do that
he had a good time he [ __ ] up got rid
of his trainer he did a lot of things
wrong they at first they were saying he
lost too much weight did you remember
that but that was just because there was
a photo that he was doing like the
Instagram oh is that it okay if you like
okay yeah like I gave nothing nothing
gives me more excited than a good boxing
match
well that fight should have been a great
fight but Andy [ __ ] up yeah he really
[ __ ] up an Appalachian
afterwards he was asking for a rematch
I'm pretty sure he trained himself to
for that yeah I think he did yeah well
he was I know for a fact why would he do
all that he was partying because he
became the heavyweight champ in the
world in an incredible knockout and I
bet everybody was kissing his ass and he
bought a Rolls Royce came to the podcast
oh yeah they did the podcast he came at
Rolls Royce yeah whoo which doesn't
necessarily mean you're going off the
rails but it's a really good invitation
yeah I mean if he showed up in a [ __ ]
Caprice Classic I believe this guy's
dialed in yeah he's focused yeah he's
gonna get this one that's got old cop
cars driving around
that's bench seats let's go get the
champion yeah he's he's Rocky Balboa
but he he had his chance and they're not
gonna give him another one no because he
can beat a lot of guys yeah but I don't
know if he could sell a lot of
pay-per-views especially after that
second performance the problem with the
second performance is the second
performance was so piss poor that you're
gonna need multiple like big wins and
fights before people take you seriously
again again and he needs a real
nutritionist he really does even though
he he won being fat there was a lot of
factors in that fight one big factor
that I have heard from people who are
very knowledgeable and in the no
insiders was that Anthony Joshua was
hurt in training that he got rocked and
maybe even got ko'd when he was training
and not not too distant from the fight
really two weeks out from the fight got
ko'd yeah oh that's not good when you're
a heavyweight and you're slinging those
[ __ ] gigantic fists at each other
like yeah all those guys need to do is
catch each other once
just once boom apparently it just
happens all the time there was a Russian
heavyweight boxer who was just
criticized because he showed this video
of a sparring session where he flatlines
his trainer or his sparring partner with
one punch happens it happens all the
time for the knockouts you see in the
ring there's probably you know dozens
more you'll never see with top fight
top-flight guys that are just you know
they're bringing in guys like when
Klitschko was the champion he brought in
guys like
the Joshua would have spar with he
brought in guys like Deontay Wilder he
sparked with the ante and Wilder I
didn't know that yeah Wow
yeah these guys I loved I loved I loved
watching down sights excited you clicked
you know at anymore exactly like you
said at any moment it can happen the
fight could turn around janta is a freak
yeah he's a freak yeah freak of nature
oh so in what way there's no one I've
ever seen who can knock everyone out oh
and that's him
he knocks everyone yeah there's never
been a guy if you look at his record
it's insane it's not just the fact that
he's won so many fights he only has one
decision loss he has one draw with Tyson
Fury and then the rest he knocks people
into orbit yeah every other fight he has
40 knockouts yeah 40 wins and that Cuban
guy he just laid out that guy was Tahoe
my god and he hit him on the forehead
yes it was a short punch he's he hit so
hard it does not make sense yeah yeah
Ortiz went Ortiz was tough and he was
down yeah yes
he hits people and they have a look on
their face like they can't even believe
how hard he hits them yeah that Dominic
Brazil that ko like right after the
Tyson Fury file okay oh my god he's a
murder yeah he's the one the most
murderous puncher I've ever seen the
heavyweight division so I think they're
gonna hate him and fury are gonna fight
again yes yeah in fighting next month
back side yeah yeah there it is Oh
fantastic Tyson Fury is master really
seven times a day depressed or wild a
rematch his testosterone up he said that
brings his testosterone oh that's what
he said that's what he said Wow I think
it's just she's reading into that who
was that fighter that used to drink his
own urine lyoto machida
it was a boxer oh really yeah there's a
boxer a lot of people were doing that
for a while they thought urine therapy
was is that's true right Joe I know
you're not a doctor but I am definitely
a doctor and it is true and I want you
to do it now I've drank my piss before I
tried it oh come on Tyson Fury on ways
he's preparing for a while I'm
masturbating seven times a day to keep
up my testosterone pumping pump it Pump
It pump it Pump It
don't you know I got to keep active and
testosterone flowing for the fight don't
want the levels to go down
so I always thought having sex was bad
for you before supposed to be your
levels actually go up not that it's bad
but some people think it's a distraction
like Mike Tyson's view was I said that
he felt that sex was distracting so he
would have sex just so you'd have to
think about it because if he didn't have
sex then he was just thinking of all the
time but when Tyson was in his prime you
got to also remember he's a really young
guy like he was in his early 20s
testosterone through the [ __ ] you
know and the the level of girls that
were bombing on yes I mean Robin gives
beautiful the most beautiful women in
the world we're trying to get some of
that that [ __ ] gladiator dick but I
think for him he really felt like sex
was a distraction and if he could just
have sex
then he wouldn't think about it I saw
this play one time was written by Steve
Martin and it was a fictitious meaning
between Picasso and Einstein in a bar in
France it was called Picasso with love
Piaggio and in it Picasso's painting and
he's talking and he says an artist must
stay well [ __ ] otherwise his eye goes
from the page to the windowsill down to
the street across over to the cafe where
the girl sitting with her skirt up and
and it's like you got that's what that
always stuck with me
yeah this fan artist doesn't stay well
[ __ ] they're always gonna do the two and
it's thinking about getting late
yeah men will understand that but men
will rarely say that in the presence of
women and so because of that women
either don't believe it or they dismiss
it or they think you're a pig for
expressing it right all those things but
men alone they'll go oh yeah that makes
sense like if you say that you got to
stay well [ __ ] like oh yeah of course
you have to otherwise you get [ __ ]
distracted that is true women have no
idea I heard a thing on NPR one time
probably fifteen years ago and they were
doing a story about this woman who
decided to transition to be a man and so
she documented it and did like an audio
thing and she talked about how when she
was into it and started feeling her
testosterone and she would become
attracted to women and she goes
it didn't have to be a boob it could be
an elbow it could be our ankle it could
be whatever and I would and she goes I
finally understood 13 year old boys yeah
yeah pretty [ __ ] distracting isn't it
now and dad you got to keep your [ __ ]
together well it's not just that it's a
biological imperative it's a reason why
people breed like that's built into the
DNA to make people attracted to females
so they can spread their DNA and that's
what it is it's that simple it's it's it
but deny that is crazy but you've got
men denying it because they want women
to like them and then you got women
dismissing it because they think that
the men who express it in an honest way
are pigs and sexist and they exhibit
toxic masculinity which is that's a
hilarious expression because you need to
thank toxic masculinity for all the
bridges all the [ __ ] all the Jets all
the rockets all this toxic masculinity
if you break down all the things that
men have invented and all these toxic
men have prevented like you from being
murdered in war and protected the
country and all these all the different
things that you could attribute a toxic
masculinity most of it's positive okay
now I forgot what this guy had this
question is it sitting in my head since
you started talking about toxic smack
salinity and I [ __ ] can't even get
the word [ __ ] sovereignty toxic
masculinity is a ridiculous thing to say
there's this terrible men there's
terrible human beings that happen to be
men there's also terrible human beings
that happen to be women there's not
toxic femininity they're just they just
have any women women who developed in a
terrible way most likely with bad
parents most likely abuse physical
and/or sexual and then they become a
monster at the end of all this process
this is the same with men bad men are
just bad human beings that happen to be
men and when you see terrible things
happen it's not because of toxic
masculinity it's because it's a bad
person I believe in the individual
there's individuals and some of them are
bad and some of them are good but you
want it if you just want to generalize
against all men like you're you're on an
uphill row there's too many and
obviously not me I've never invented
anything but there's too many things
that men have done
that are positive there's way too many
there's too many thing if you wanted to
have like Russia a scoreboard and you
wanted to compete men versus women
why would what are you gonna say when
you look at all the different
accomplishments that men have made and
obviously it's not me and it's not you
I'm not talking about us like we're on a
team but I'm saying like just this this
concept that men are bad and you hear
this a lot today especially white man I
don't wanna hear from white man okay
well that's crazy because there's a lot
of nice white men like this is dumb Phil
Donahue yeah he's one of them but just
just this idea that you can generalize
about one entire group whether it's by
gender or whether it's by race but by
anything but you can do that with white
men you can't really do that with brown
women you can't say here's a problem
with black women you know all black
women are this that people go you're a
racist piece of [ __ ] what do you say
here's the problem with white men both
are gross both statements so
generalizations are disgusting whether
they're a gender-based generalization or
sex based generals whatever it is so
they would say that that's okay to say
that about white men because of the
power dynamic yes that white men have
power so if we say that it doesn't is
not even racist right right that's what
that's I don't know I'm not a dumb
argument got a professor so I don't know
if that's true or not but you know what
the white power this is thing white men
have more power sure but they also have
more power than white men
it's a tiny percentage of white men
white men who have the power that we're
talking about when you're talking about
CEOs and you're talking about you know
judges or what is it yes yes white men
are in those positions of power but
they're also in those positions of power
over most white men like it's it's not
it's it's a very small amount of people
that have an extraordinary amount of
influence yeah they happen to be white
men but when you say white men suck look
at this like no that's that's the
smallest percentage of people who are
these billionaires who are these CEOs
who are these judges who are these
people that are in positions of power
that happen to be white men so have you
ever now again I don't know I heard a
guy refer to himself
a regular guy refer to himself as a sis
mile
how many do that from now on have that
has anyone ever done that
it kind of blew me I can't even know
what it was when I first heard it yeah
it's nonsense well you're male if you're
a trans woman and you you want to be
referred to only as a woman fine no
problem with that but I'm not gonna call
myself a sis male that's some new
made-up [ __ ] it sounds like you're
calling yourself [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah like when I first heard it gender I
thought that's what a guy was doing when
if when I first heard it a guy said I'm
assist male blah blah blah I'm like
you're a [ __ ] I didn't know what it
meant I read this tweet once by this
person who was saying basically to shame
people into using that Ram it down their
throats and eventually they'll accept it
and it'll become normal and that you
have because if they want to refer to us
as trans we have to refer to them as
says we have to force them process yes
yeah I even know that's where it came
it's to just to make a clear distinction
so instead of making it look like a
trans woman is lesser you set.you
instead of that you have cisgender and
transgender so they're there because
you're you're adding to that name that
prefix yeah because you're adding to
both now yeah now you've equalize the
playing field you level the playing
field but the problem with that is trans
is extremely rare it's the reason why
you have that prefix in the first place
because it's really really unusual to
meet a trans woman despite how the
internet would have you feel
I was always I'm sure it's a tough life
to be a transgender yes I'm like
incredibly tough I was always a little
jealous why don't you become a woman I
was always like god it looks like fun
why don't you dress up like Megan McCain
and just start going on rants on your
show you'd be free he would have such a
[ __ ] free pass
I mean look Caitlyn Jenner killed a lady
nobody would talk CEO says anything no
just slammed her into traffic not paying
attention rear-ended her into oncoming
traffic she's dead now and no one even
brings it up everyone's like she's so
brave do you think she's intact
I heard she cut it off oh my god it's a
con I yeah I don't but that was accident
right it wasn't like it was a
careless accident Oh still she
rear-ended somebody and slammed her into
oncoming traffic okay and whether or not
she was on her phone I don't know do you
ever worry you're gonna say something
I've always worried like I'm ignorant
above a like I said that big gaps yeah a
knowledge of stuff and so I remember I
was was I talking about the other day
and I got it totally wrong like I didn't
know like somebody from the what Jamaica
that's also an African American I didn't
know that sure because they came over
from Africa that's a guess I'm talking
about how dumb I would say African
American my guess once they came to
America and they're American citizens
African America yeah so I didn't again
this is a lot of Jamaicans refer
themselves as Jamaicans though the thing
about Jamaicans is like it's really
unique I like unique cultures are known
for like specific things that are very
positively Jamaicans are known for
incredible work ethic yeah Jamaicans
have multiple jobs it's always a
stand-up job kidding yeah yeah in New
York there was always jokes about
Jamaicans about you know that they would
get mad if you had less than five jobs
oh no kidding yeah Jamaicans are known
for being like very hustle oriented see
that's a New York thing I mean the only
thing I've ever heard about Jamaicans is
the stereotype of pot no that's 2.2 but
they have a lot of jobs hot smokers
having five job skills to show you it
doesn't take away your ambition they
don't it does it's that that's nonsense
look I smoked a lot of pot I'm pretty
ambitious I work a lot that's it do you
ever so I'll do a show right where I'm
like criticizing someone or something
and then I'll smoke a joint afterwards
to relax
and then I start every day yeah
definitely okay we're talking [ __ ] yeah
I know no I mean I'm thinking about my
poorly worded rant of male versus women
and I'm thinking like well I promise
just said that better but that's just
part of how it works you know when I was
getting out but from all of this though
is that we have to look at each other as
individuals and this identity politics
[ __ ] that people play whether it's
male versus female whether it's black
versus white and Asian and this and that
we they have to be humans humans first
and one of the weirder things that's
going on in
now is there there's leaning so hard on
diversity that it gets distracting it's
like it gets like I want to see is an
example I went to see frozen the musical
frozen is about in Nordic there's Nordic
people one the girl has magic do you
ever see it you'll have kids I don't
know I don't in the play in the musical
the dad is black and the mom's Chinese
which is like okay maybe she's Asian
I don't know maybe she's Korean I don't
know it's hard to tell I can't see that
good I'm 52 okay far away but she was
obviously Asian and then they have a kid
and then the young version of the kid is
Asian and then the old version of the
kid later in the musical is white and
like you're distracting the fun yeah
that's described you distract the [ __ ]
out but how does a black guy and an
Asian lady make to to blonde ladies look
what's happening or one is right here
how that happened how the black guy and
the Chinese lady make a blonde a union
worship but I guess like don't you cut
continuity they're just it's distracting
the gay was great in his role she was
great in her role they were excellent it
worked I accepted it and moved up but I
know what you're doing you know if you
had a white guy playing a black guy in a
movie I'd be like what is happening here
why is this white guy pretending to be a
black guy this is does this is are we
gonna address this like if there was a
musical and there was a guy and we
decided we'll just have a white guy play
the the father of you know some some
black guy and we're just not gonna say
why he had a kid that was black we just
assume that you'll figure it out or just
you just you know yeah that's that
breaks the fourth wall it breaks your
but you what do you think I'm suspending
my disbelief and then you're doing
things that make me disbelieve it's
distracting it's distracting but I
understand that the doing I appreciate
it yeah because I think ultimately what
it is is it's all a all of it is moving
in the right direction it's just doing
it in a very clunky way they're moving
against discrimination they're moving
against races and they're moving for
cultural diversity beautiful but it's
just distracting the way they're doing
is so art but it's like
Hollywood is so gross they lick their
finger they have no virtue they lick
their fingers which way the wind blowing
this way I mean we need Asians and
they'll just [ __ ] just start hiring
Asians for things and trying to get
Asian people jobs and try to look look
look look we have Asians we're really
and that if it becomes Jamaicans
Jamaicans we need Jamaicans get them in
here get them in here they don't give a
[ __ ] they're trying to make money
they're trying to make money and one of
the best ways to make money is to ride
cultural trends and so our cultural
trend right now is it good one even
though there's a lot of people that are
there they're basically they're
controversy pimps right so when these
things come up they use this controversy
to gain money or notoriety or push their
cause or to use it as the wind behind
their sail cuz they can talk a lot of
[ __ ] about other people and get a lot of
attention it gives them a bit of
immunity yes it gives them a lot of
immunity yeah and so like all these
things it of course yeah
how have you experienced it I've had
people accuse me being sexist as I've
had that clearly established you were so
excited yeah well of course I am because
I because I treat women equally yes
that's the problem yeah I've caught you
know I would sexist because I voted for
Jill Stein both anybody that says you're
sexist for making fun of Elizabeth
Warren dancing is a [ __ ] buffoon
that's a perfect example of what I'm
talking about like are you saying that
you a person running for the
commander-in-chief of the greatest army
the world has ever known and you can't
make fun of the way they dance cuz they
have a vagina [ __ ] you I am woman hear
me roar and they'll make fun of my
dancing or my roars again it's like the
I thought the answer to this was to
treat everybody equally yes it's how it
should be we would but identity politics
the real problem that of course always
is that you cannot ever say this is a
man so he must be that this is a woman
so she must be that this is a black
person so they must be this that's those
generalizations are bad for everybody
people are nuanced and if we don't
believe in the individual then we don't
really believe in equality we have to
everyone has to have their own way to
make it through this life and express
themselves in a unique way where they
can contribute in a unique way and we
could appreciate them for who they are
not appreciate them as a
woman or appreciate them as a man or as
a white man or a black woman or what
that's nonsense it's so dumb like you
happen you might happen to be a black
man or you might happen to be an Asian
man you might happen to be all those
things but you're a person you're a
[ __ ] individual and we should
especially when it comes to meritocracy
things like positions of power and
government like get elected officials or
even comedians or anything else I mean
you you want to make sure that the
person who's this is they're good so
they're just good there's yes so there's
that yeah but then there's there's also
this other little part of it like so
even someone who say doesn't have the
pedigree like there's a white guy from
Harvard right he has the crew straight
A's the greatest whatever and then you
might get a a - student who's a minority
from stoma or B+ student and that would
be more effective to have in a position
because they have a different world
experience so a meritocracy in a sense
kind of leaves out some people who were
have different hurdles to get over and
have different life experiences that
this person won't have you know seeing
I'm saying like you become the people
you're surrounded by so Eve you might be
an african-american but a or so it's
it's more important to have different
economic represented because you can be
really smart like Chelsea Clinton but
she doesn't know what it's like to have
to have her medicine just to know what
it's like to have to drop a pharmacy to
get medicine for her daughter or you
know it means like she might be super
smart but she doesn't have this
information that we need which is like
when FDR when he was doing the banks and
stuff he got a banker from Texas he
didn't go to Wall Street ago you mean he
got regular people to come in so that
there's something to that - right so
straight meritocracy well there it is a
meritocracy in that there's merit in
their life experience oh okay what if
those individuals that live these
difficult lives like I think that's one
of the greatest currencies that a person
really carries with them in their life
is their experience overcoming adversity
their experience overcoming adversity
shapes their character is and when you
meet someone me maybe you meet this
woman
and she she has you know all bees
through college but she's been through a
lot of [ __ ] and she's uniquely clever
and how she handles things and you
talked her and you look at her record
and you go you know what I like you
better than this guy who got all A's cuz
he seems kind of like yes spectrum me
and he's not gonna like to fit in with
my company but yeah that makes sense but
that again we're just you don't just
look at meritocracy don't just look at
grades you look at the human overall the
individual and there's a lot of benefit
to people that have overcome difficult
lives like those people come out
interesting those people come out
important because they they've they've
seen some [ __ ] that you haven't seen yes
that's that is what and they're and they
understand things that you don't
understand yes and that's why I like
soil like a guy like Barack Obama could
have a diverse cabinet but they're all
from the same class right that's fake
diverse that's fake diversity yes so
they're all he still he served he served
the establishment power like any white
president did and his cabinet did the
same thing by the way his cabinet came
from an email from Citigroup which I
know you know yeah yeah you know we are
it's these things are complicated that's
part of the problem with any of these
conversations and also they're so loaded
when you talk about men or women or
black or white anything like everybody's
on edge like don't say anything stupid
right what how do you feel really like
oh well I'm white so I don't have those
experiences so I always try to limit how
I talk about it like I always say I
shouldn't be talking about this because
I I don't have you should be talking
about anything you want to talk about
this idea that you could be silenced
because you're you're not in some
protected group that's nonsense I've
always a well I'm always afraid I'm
going to say something ridiculous and
ignorant which I do often yeah me too
I'm gonna save ignorant ridiculous [ __ ]
like this you have to have the ability
to say ignorant ridiculous [ __ ] if
you're gonna have a free-flowing
conversation like you and I so we didn't
even talk on the phone before this we
had no idea what we're gonna talk about
we right into a pre-interview we did
nothing but coming
Capri will be hilarious would you start
talking about farts [ __ ] free we were
talking about Jimmy I don't know yeah it
would Jack it up seven times a day to
keep my testosterone let's talk about
that yeah get it get it get it
pre-interviews they still do
pre-interviews under do you by the way
do you ever watch any of those shows
ever no no one does very few people are
watching those I mean Conan O'Brien get
less views than my show no no that's why
that's why they're all doing podcasts
now I know a [ __ ] joke there was a
crazy article that Conan O'Brien is
leading the way in new media yes like
what are you talking about we've been
doing this [ __ ] for 15 years pages and
this thing what the photos even get good
numbers of his podcast no no like the
actual download speed does alright but
he doesn't do as good as like Dax
Shepard or me or any of the people that
are at the top of the heap and vomiting
well be you know you use your platform
Jo to actually have real conversations
and say no I haven't listened the Conan
Brian's a podcast because you know I've
got anything else to do but he's
interviewing famous people yeah it's
[ __ ] the same [ __ ] and it's not I
mean hate Marc Maron's got that covered
right he did that he'll doing it for ten
[ __ ] years that's right people opened
up to their heart never so he has this
thing and then you do this other thing
it's [ __ ] covered you aren't breaking
any new debt was crazy that head that
was a New York Times headline wasn't a
joke I think it was always a variety
variety and everybody in Hollywood was
like what in the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah yeah
and what was funny too yeah I got tagged
on it so many times I'm like I'm not
even gonna comment because I can't it's
Conan O'Brien he's revolution I see I
was changing the game he stays at the
game
cuz they gave he had a photo shoot yeah
he's a white man a bright problem he has
assists male he's another one of those
white man at the top of podcasting it's
[ __ ] yeah I don't know if he's at
the top of podcasting I wouldn't say
that all of it it's just gross did you
ever do his show no yeah I did a show
before a couple times they sell seem
like nice people he's a nice guy he
seems like nice they all seem like very
nice people I feel bad when I go after
them on Twitter
Andy Richter all the chords you do I go
after a trick to go after it easy I can
tell he's a nice guy I can know it well
because you know he's famous right and
it's white male and he's white male
problems very safe for me to go after
him but he they there's this Hollywood
mentality on the left right and this
Hollywood mentality on the left is that
all bad things started in January 2017
they have no idea how we got there so
he's tweeting out this stuff about how
Trump is has the cognition of an
eight-year-old right because he wants to
do war crimes and so I went you know
well how quick can you believe this guy
I'm like dude they've been [ __ ] doing
war crime since I was born
why are you acting like this just
started we're just we don't ever
prosecute them and they're not gonna
prosecute him for war crimes why are you
[ __ ] dude you know what war criminals
do they go and dance with Ellen on
daytime television
that's the cognition of Hollywood
Michelle Obama says George Bush and her
have the exact same values a war
criminal she has the exact said that's
the cognition of a [ __ ] of first lady
I'm gonna talk about cognition how we
[ __ ] got here and you're smarter than
that Andy Richter and that's why I hold
his feet to the fire I know he's a nice
guy but he just locked into that
although it's a tall team that's all
[ __ ] vote Balu no matter who it's all
it's all forget how we got here let's
forget that Barack Obama was
unbelievably corrupt which is why we
don't have a functioning banking system
which is why I don't have a functioning
health care system which we why he took
us from two wars to seven which is why
he had a Peace Prize and a [ __ ] kill
list where's my kill list oh maybe it's
underneath my peace prize and use it as
a paperweight kind of ironically anyway
these are the things that I try to focus
on Joe by the way I was right about all
of them yeah and I was right about
[ __ ] Russia gate you were but the
beautiful you want to do a victory lap
yet you should it's been around your
chair the thing about you though is like
you are a left-wing guide that's willing
to criticize the left and for some
people that seems to get the problem a
boo thing like they don't want to talk
about the left oh you can't I'm first of
all so I found out that people who want
to make it in the Democratic Party are
not allowed to come to my shows no I was
doing a show and this woman who I know
who was involved in the democratic
politics I kind of want to say anything
about who they are because they'll get
in trouble and
she came to my show and she goes you
know this other person who's climbing in
the Democratic Party was supposed to
come with me and at the last minute she
didn't and I called her ass didn't want
you come and she goes you know if I get
seen at a jimmy dore show my career in
the democratic party's over
oh come on Harris I could tell by your
accent you racist piece of [ __ ] I could
tell
couldn't you tell Jimmy I could tell and
I'm like she's she ever been on your
show Kabbalah her yes oh oh we did some
quick easy FBI work right there sorry
the way that made me feel good that
makes me feel like I want to be an
outsider I don't want I want people to
be afraid of me they're afraid you know
well I don't know if they are but they
won't come on my show so that's good and
well my show was never about guests my
show was all about my opinion course and
calling out [ __ ] yeah so it's that's
nobody doing the right thing you doing
I'm doing the wrong thing because they
all keep asking to be on my show okay
I have a request from all of them really
oh yeah Biden Warren how do youhow do
you resist [ __ ] cuz I'm I have my
friends talk to my friends yeah I know I
would get a phone call see and I like I
like burning that's it oh yeah everybody
else can eat [ __ ] look at you [ __ ]
progressive yeah well I've always been
yeah what yeah everyone says your right
wing they're out of their [ __ ] mind
I've never voted right-wing in my life
really never never voted Democrat except
for independent I voted for Gary Johnson
cuz he did my podcast people don't
realize how far like yeah I'm not I'm
not right-wing at all okay that's while
no there's nothing about me this
right-wing yeah kill your own food
that's it well that's crazy
there's 95 plus percent of the
population the planet eats meat I just
happen to kill my own yeah that's a it's
not like 95 percent of the population is
right-wing because they kill their own
food I think there's a lot of right-wing
like family values and things like that
that I admire I think but when when you
can't when it gets to homophobia when it
gets to women's rights that's where I
break right I'm a hundred percent in
favor of women's rights 100 percent in
favor of gay rights gay marriage I'm a
big proponent of the there's got to be
some new action taken to clean up a lot
of these
crime-ridden communities and the idea
that we can spend all this money
overseas we can't spend money on Flint
Michigan or Detroit or the southside of
Chicago that to me is insane that
doesn't make any sense and this idea
that we're all in the same starting page
is so [ __ ] stupid - that that is a
very non right-wing way of looking at it
because everybody's like you got to pull
yourself up by your bootstraps there's a
lot of people that came out of bad
neighborhoods but they didn't they
didn't [ __ ] cry what was me they just
went out there and they kicked ass
that's nonsense
you have no idea what it's like to grow
up in a crime-ridden poverty infested
drug-addled neighborhood you don't know
what that's like and we should make it
so that no one knows what that's like if
we want America better the best way to
start is to clean up all the spots that
suck and make people that are coming out
of there have a real chance and making
something out of their life don't don't
have it so that they're starting out
from the time they're a child with a
massive deficit that's me and what you
mean by clean cleaning up the plate it
mean Community Programs putting money
into these communities jobs not just
jobs but community programs where kids
have a safe place to go that's a big
part of it protect them from the gangs
put more cops in those neighborhoods and
have them there all the time make them a
part of the community they got to do
something about the violence and do
something about the gangs and this
repetitive cycle of people growing up in
these neighborhoods and getting trapped
in these same horrible conditions that
their parents did or their grandparents
did and it's an endless cycle we and we
pretend like we don't have the resources
to fix the FDR did FDR whenever you want
a job I'll give you a job that means
you're gonna go work it's not I'm not
giving you anything you're earning it
and guess what we have the money for it
wouldn't it be amazing if they did that
there could be strategies that are
implemented they might all not all work
but I don't see like I don't anything is
doing yeah yeah we're gonna help we're
gonna have Enterprise Zones yeah
obviously and then and then they want
the school to fix all the problems of
the community no what you need is jobs
this what people need is something to
look forward they need to know that they
can fade you play by the rules they will
get things you could have a job right
now those people were gonna and they
don't have any health care right and
they get broken their life goes upside
down I mean you know how I have I have a
job but I got sick my life got turned
upside
because of bills and this is not just
black communities either we're talking
about the coal mining communities in
West Virginia that horrific man you
don't even like I have a good friend
it's from there it's like man you don't
know what poverty is like you don't even
know what poverty is like until you see
that nothing I talked to a guy on my
show his name is Nick Smith from
Virginia and he told me he was a Waffle
House cook and he told me and I might
even told you this before he said hey we
all knew that Donald Trump was a
loudmouth Yankee who should have had his
ass kicked a long time ago but Hillary
Clinton wasn't offering us anything so
he was at least offering us something
right so they're desperate these people
need something
she wouldn't even sign on to a $15
minimum wage what she was ready was it
but the [ __ ] wrong with you yeah well
she didn't even believe in gay marriage
until 2013 how about that 2000 [ __ ]
13 she did when she came around with gay
marriage yeah you're you are you're
ahead of her on that weren't you Joe
yeah well I actually lived in San
Francisco around gay people and I was
real little really 7 to 11 my family
lived right off of Lombard Street Nokia
we lived in San Francisco and the height
of the I mean it was the Vietnam War
there's all these hippies myself as a
hippie
oh no kidding yeah so it's like I mean
I've been liberal my whole life I just
look like a Republican you know yeah I
think attend beat the [ __ ] out of people
I'd like some violent things and I have
guns and you know there's a lot of
things that you could make an inference
like oh that guy seems like you would be
but no I my friend my friend Graham
Elwood is do you know him sure he's he
was on his live stream the other day and
he's a very anti-war like me and so
these people were [ __ ] with him be
pro war and he's like that's right I'll
knock you out that's right you ever been
knocked out by a vegetarian stack
cellairis well that's another group that
people like to play identity politics
with what are you eating
you know how much how much of that is so
you with the meat so my doctor doctor
strep so no you I have a special bone
broth Sharpe from Pasadena that's tough
holy [ __ ] so he tells me yes he he
always does this like this right he goes
oh Jimmy you're from Chicago you eat
right deep dish pizza right sweet and I
go I go yep try not to and he goes why I
go you know I said global warming I saw
cows jumping like dogs
bouncing around yeah I can't eat me I
can't eat pork this get it that is
county pork pork is Shady
I can't do it but but wild pigs must be
stopped
oh there they they can kill you right
over swallowers they killed a lady in
texas and ate her they found her on an
elderly lady they found her in her
driveway torn apart by wild pigs yeah
she was on her way out to the car and
she just ran to a pack of him they took
her out a pack yeah yeah yeah I've seen
videos those things are but I have to
kill them there's so many of them and
they breed so quickly they bleed they
have four in a litter they'll have four
litters in a year
really yeah bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang that's why there's millions
and millions of wild pigs they started
with just a few pigs that were on like
the Pinta or the Santa Maria or some
[ __ ] and they spread across the entire
country but once you find out that they
have emotions
yes that's process what I can't hit I
can't do that they have them all you
shoot them from a distance
you don't want to get up close so so
your theory is they don't know it's
coming
no that is a good way to do it what did
they done their mother what if you have
a pig and you kill the pigs well do that
if you're an ethical hunter you know you
don't shoot a pig that has piglets yeah
you try to avoid that unless about a
deal the only time they do they don't do
that either
that's illegal oh the only time they do
do that though in some places illegal
the only time they do do that with pigs
is when they're trying to eradicate all
of them like there's some farm lands
that experience just devastating losses
because of wild pigs and especially in
Texas millions and millions of dollars a
year which cripples these companies they
go under because the wild pigs like
these some farms can literally go bang
oh my god you'd have no idea what it's
like unless you've been around them but
what about fig pig farming right that's
a different thing most pig farming is
disgusting I can't it's horrible but
then there's there's ethical pig farms
where they raise these pigs where they
get let them roam around how the meat
looks different
they're eating acorns and natural food
really yeah there's a guy named Joel
Salatin and he runs this farm called
Polyface farms and he's all about
regenerative farming and he discusses
like how like the way animals live best
is the way they live natural yeah and
they used to put chickens are supposed
to roam free so he has this portable
chicken house and they roll it into a
new field and then the chickens going to
the chicken house at night and in the
morning they come out and then they go
roam around and they move it to another
spot so they eat all the bugs and all
the grass and all the stuff in the area
and then they move to a new spot and so
they raise chickens and the eggs are
healthier the the pigs the the pork is
healthier these these pigs are wandering
around in these open areas and then they
Corral them and then they then they kill
them quickly
I just once I found out either they have
real emotions like dogs I just think
about my dog and now I just I just fall
apart I can't I hear you but wild pigs
are different yeah that's different
because they're an invasive species you
know they actually morph they change
shape when they become like a wild pig
and a domestic pig is the same animal
like people talk about all-russian wild
boar it's all nonsense it's all sooo
scrofa it's all one genus it's the same
animal really yeah really when a wild
when a pig a domestic pig goes wild I
mean it's different versions of them but
they can all breed with each other when
a domestic pig goes wild like say if you
had a domestic Pig and you said go ahead
porky be free and you open up your gate
within weeks within weeks they start to
physically change their snout starts to
lengthen their hair gets thicker and
bushier and their tusks grow no kid yes
they literally become what you think of
when you think of wild boars it just
takes a while but they fit they're one
of the weirder animals they're almost
like gremlins when you feed him after
midnight when you let him go they start
changing they morph so I did I so dr.
Sharpe says to me from Pasadena
he says he said well you should eat meat
and I'm like because of my condition
right and he tells this long story about
how we evolved he sits down and starts
telling me
and about how we were cavemen and inside
the glaciers and the thing and he's like
so you should eat meat especially you
because of your condition and I go okay
well how often and he goes every day and
I was like Jesus I can't do that you
know and so but this is medical advice
from a guy who saved my life right so
it's like I eat meat a couple times a
week do you feel better or worse we need
it I do have more energy
yeah well that's probably good right
yeah why not meet more often I have just
because if you don't have to eat pork I
know if you eat humanely rate me
so there's great grass yeah you can buy
grass-fed grass-finished meat from
farmers that have a commitment to
humanely raised and humanely euthanized
animals I want to euthanize killed
killed animals and they when the way
they kill them when they harvest them
they just lead him into a pen they have
no idea what's coming and they put a
bowl to their head and bang they take
them out yeah it can't it can be done in
a way where the animal has no idea what
happens until it tilts over
mm-hmm and it's not like they're gonna
live forever I mean obviously this is a
slippery argument cause you say that
about people too okay this guy's an
[ __ ] let's just kill him it's not
he's gonna live forever all right
you don't want to say that but the the
the quality of the meat is far better if
the animal is living a natural life
right you're talking about organic no
hormones no yeah no corn manage it's
terrible for cows they're not supposed
to eat that did their the the ruminants
they eat [ __ ] grass that's what they
do when they're at their best and
healthiest and healthiest for you
there's better fatty acids in it's just
healthier for you and so and so you
think if you went vegetarian it would be
bad for your health I don't know I don't
think it I think it's definitely doable
I definitely think you can go vegetarian
and and be healthy but you have to be
really careful about a lot of your
nutrient levels you have to really make
sure you get enough vitamin D a lot of
b12 you gotta check your essential fatty
acid levels there's a lot of stuff but
like it looks real good on paper but
then you find out it's not bioavailable
I tried to go vegan for a while
and I got I got fat well it's a lot of
cars yeah just you know I didn't know
what I know what I was doing I wasn't
doing it right whatever
yeah I'm not a like soy why don't I
sound like tofu little [ __ ] yeah just
something about it did you [ __ ] with any
of that vegan chicken stuff or any of
those weird ones that are make them look
like real food there's a name for that
oh no no book that fake meat they have
now is fantastic really bad for you
though do you know that actually causes
liver problems and rats what yeah pull
up the fake meat liver problems rats
no yeah look it's all oils so that
stuff's all kind of assess food oils
it's processed vegetable oils and then
add yeah just eat [ __ ] vegetables man
if you want to be a vegetarian eat
vegetables look most boys a lot of
people who would say regular burgers not
good for you either but of course a
regular burger is just me with bread and
all the [ __ ] the bread and all the
[ __ ] is what's bad for you it's not
the burger itself as long as it's an
actual meat burger particularly if it's
a grass-fed burger yeah so what is he
pulling up he's pulling up this study
about one of the meet the one of them
impossible order beyond meat one of them
but they were talking about how there's
studies that are showing that this this
is not but then again they're not
marketing it as a healthy alternative no
their marketing is a meat-free Berger &
Berger is kind of like a fun food anyway
here it is rat feeding studies suggest
the impossible burger may not be safe to
eat ello [ __ ] ha but if you go to the
ingredients man I've had scientists
relay the ingredients to me I thought it
was just coconut oil oh it's a bunch of
fat up stuff because they've got to make
it seem like it's a real burger someone
heme is that thing they that makes it
taste like it's called heme heme heme
iron some like that that's what gives it
that flavor that people are looking for
getting that I don't know where they get
that for a boil in green that good it's
a People's joke it's people that sucks
yes sucks well it's so you don't think
I'll ever stop eating me do you think
you'll always you'll you're like animals
are here for us to eat and that's that I
don't think that I think we definitely
evolved a human animal evolved from
eating meat and that's not
that's not under debate I mean we
evolved from eating meat and weirdo
vegans to try to say crazy [ __ ] like oh
why don't we have canines how come we
can't eat meat raw well because [ __ ]
we figured out fire a long [ __ ] time
ago and our bodies adapt it because of
that our teeth adapted because we
figured out how to cut things with
utensils and we figured out how to cook
things so they're more tender it's it's
not as simple as like why do we have an
appendix why is that I'll tell you why
because we used to eat differently and
we still have a leftover organ some
weird [ __ ] organ from for breaking
down bark and [ __ ] you know we don't
need that anymore would any bark anymore
is that what that's like roots and stuff
like oh we yeah I think that's what the
appendix is for I think it was initially
for breaking down like very hard to
digest fibrous things so I have my
gallbladder out whoa what did you do
with it I'm gonna put it back in yeah
I'm thinking about it I have it in my
glove box but what happened
no I his head yeah I was having
gallbladder attacks I thought it was a
heart attack whoa where's so in it it
was like right here oh jeez and I always
heard like your heart attack feels like
it's in the center and this was this was
a little lower I'm like this is a heart
attack I'm dying this is no doubt I'm
dying I thought for sure I was dying so
I'm on the couch and I remember I'm just
like this is my wife calls the fireman
and I'm just like this is it this is how
it's gonna happen I was kind of okay
with it right but I was in because I was
in a lot of pain I wanted it to end I
was like okay if I die I die well then
they came and they shot me and I was
like oh I feel fantastic again so it
wasn't it was just my gobbler they took
it out and what does it do
the gallbladder secretes bile into your
stomach to help digest things right so
gallbladder is would be like the four
bile and your liver makes bile it like
your reservoir so now I don't have a
reservoir anymore well so now it just is
always kind of dripping does it [ __ ]
with you anymore
you know it's [ __ ] with me a lot in
lots of different ways yeah my my
appetite is tastes weird when you get
nervous it doesn't come it doesn't come
on slowly it's that's why you had to eat
when you're on stage so that happens so
that and then and often often after I
eat I have to go right I have to go the
bathroom right away
right away yeah I don't know ever since
I had my gobbler I don't know if other
people have that I haven't googled it
now was there any alternative to getting
it removed did they say hey maybe you
could change your diet I was not given a
alternative there was so there's you
have like calcium and deposits in your
thing and they block the duck and then
you don't that's what causes all the
pain and so eventually it'll dislodge
itself and the pain will go away but it
could kill you if it stays and doesn't
go away and so they have to take it out
Jesus Christ
yeah and guess huh so here's a great
story about our medical system right Joe
so I have Blue Cross insurance I had the
best that you could buy or what have you
and so I had my second gallbladder
attack and I was like I got to get this
goddamn thing out because I can't have
this happen again it hurts too much
right so I called the doctor and they're
like I can't even get a consultation for
three weeks in network to get it so I
have to get a consultation then I have
to wait wait another three or four weeks
to get the operation so this could maybe
be two months before I get the operation
of these ten I'm gonna have another
goddamn attack so I had went out of
network and I got another doctor to come
take care of me faster so I couldn't
have to worry about the other side to
pay out of pocket
god damn yes so this whole thing you're
gonna have to wait you have to [ __ ]
wait right now yeah it's ridiculous what
you actually know it's true it is true
it is true I have friends and candidates
way worse up there though about waiting
yeah if you like I had French needed in
the operation they waited a [ __ ] year
so for a whole year she's walking around
with a torn ACL really dub knee yeah a
whole year a year 12 months 365 days I
was the hobbling around do you know
anybody in Canada would that would trade
their health care plan for a United
States I didn't want to pay for it once
you don't have to pay for it you don't
want to pay for it you know you know
there's a great video where this guy
interviews people in England and he
asked them how much do you think sauce
to be married or how much does a baby to
have a baby and they're like $100 try
ten grand he's like what what yeah I saw
it yeah everybody freaks out everybody
freaks yeah well once you're used to
things being free you don't want to pay
for them I don't look I think healthcare
should be free I really do I think
education should be free I think if
we're gonna spend money as a community
if we have a gigantic
community of people and that's what a
country really is it's a community
what is the most important thing to take
care of well we got to take care of old
people sick people we got to take care
of poor people we got to take like this
is this the idea that somehow or another
that this is uh this is a foolish notion
that you have to take care of people
that education it wouldn't be better if
more people are educated yeah so why
shouldn't that be free well we don't
have the money but we have how much
money how much hundred and thirty one
extra billion they gave trouble would
that be a lot of Education yeah a lot of
people learn [ __ ] that way yeah it's
almost that's double the money it would
take to send everybody to college for
free that's hilarious sixty five billion
dollars a year send everybody to college
they just spent 131 billion to give gift
to him that's double right I'm not a
math surgeon but I'm pretty sure that's
double Masergy
I think if we figured out a way to you
know you know Ari Shaffir says the same
stuff yeah I was just on his show and he
was saying we gotta take care of
homeless people I'm like I thought you
were a right winger
oh he's not right way at all I guess not
Ari's very left-wing why do you think
everybody was right-wing cuz we talked
[ __ ] I don't know I just hear it you
know on social media all those idiots
they just think because I've talked to
Alex Jones or because I've had you know
right-wing people on that you know oh
your platforming people joke I've been
friends with Alex Jones since the 90s
I've known that guy forever so when I
went in that never tell you the story
when you spin his face so on so when the
ice tea's accidentally I got so um
so whatever first I didn't think that
would be that big of a deal wowthat's or
not to be a big deal right right so then
whatever so then the next day I talked
to some people from his show we're all
friends right but not him and so I went
down like a couple months later did you
uh Austin so I go to this the the steak
house right and there forgets the name
it's the big place right try to cross
tree from the Weston and so I'm there my
brother came down for the weekend my
brother and his wife and we're all
sitting there we're eating and all of a
sudden goes Alex Jones just walked in he
sitting right behind you I go get the
[ __ ] out or he's gonna come present your
organ but my brother's big guy right so
mom my brothers are bigger than me and
and tough to write and so I was like
alright well if you see him coming this
way
No so he's back and he goes he just sat
down he shook hands with this guy three
times I go it sounds like they're up to
something I go and we were luckily we
were eight finishing and I was like okay
I'm not gonna I'm gonna finish it I'm
gonna walk the [ __ ] that's hilarious
just get out here slick he could crush
me he probably wouldn't you would be
able to talk to him he's a lot more
reasonable than people think he is
and especially now now he's not drinking
anymore oh really he's been off booze
for [ __ ] I want to say many many months
now yeah it's been quite a while he is
no drinking she's changed - he's he's
realized he was losing his [ __ ] mind
was getting deep platform he was
drinking like a bottle bottle a half of
vodka every night yeah he was going four
times I kind of stand with people do you
like that what we need and when you do
drink that much you do get psychotic
like you start dude I love drinking and
I can't
I don't drink like I used to anymore
because older - right in I wake up the
next day I'm depressed
yeah yep I love drinking martinis during
a live show everything's wrong
everything's bad I'm this but you know
what a lot of that is a lot of is not
just the alcohol it's also the
dehydration oh yeah yeah if you just
hydrate and take a lot of electrolytes
you think yeah yeah you can mitigate a
lot of that stuff also glutathione
glutathione can help your body process
alcohol quicker glutathione Lewis I own
yeah it's an antioxidant super potent
antioxidant yeah it actually your body
produces it and aids in the process of
processing alcohol I didn't know yeah I
can help you a little bit my little
boost I did drink in Hawaii they have
them couldn't stop drinking them they
taste oh yeah that's a problem when
things are delicious but yet also get
you far Kalka halt yeah but the Adam
wasn't driving anywhere I didn't ever do
anything so bizarre there was to be a
place in West Palm Beach improv and
downstairs they had one of those
alcoholic
Slurpee places oh no
yeah they taste [ __ ] blessed man one
of them called call a cab and you would
drink it it was like I drank one onstage
once and by the end of the show I was
like thank God the show ended the way it
did I forgot how to talk really oh my
god it was so sloshed by the time the
show was over I was one glass I mean one
like it was like a big gulp sighs call a
cab I don't know how many drinks shot
one or like seven shots to load but it's
like a giant mix right yeah it's just
like 7-eleven Slurpees yeah it tastes
good mmm it tastes good and you get
[ __ ] up yeah I've never heard that
[ __ ] up on stage there was a time when
I was I was going through a phase where
I dropped my pants on stage oh you
stopped doing that I did people start to
complain why I don't know how much this
is the oldest comic gig in the [ __ ]
gig and the thing it's just a gag you
drop your pager Lewis is funny did you
have underwear on yeah oh yeah are you
Ahri's pulls his hog out not anymore
Lily scared can you do that is in the
day you can still pull your hog out he
pulled his hog out and a skank fest in
New York they had a you know skank fest
again I don't not familiar you gotta get
in the loop I know I'm out of it did a
few weeks ago that killed Tony yeah
let's talk out yeah yeah right before he
was here I preferred maybe Tony was here
one of the times where was it oh yeah
well probably shouldn't say that what
wasn't be illegal
well I used to do it Joe rubber dick
don't worry about it folks I used to do
it and yeah and then nobody noticed that
I was embarrassing
yeah Joe just sometimes I do jokes all
right okay what am I here with my father
no it's okay it's all fine it's all fine
ari has always done ridiculous [ __ ] he
used to go on stage with his balls out
of his pants address it so go onstage
and do his act he would just unzip his
pants pull a sack out and then just have
it at the store where there's like
someone onstage Joey bombing and yes
Joey bomb it was a woman on stage she
was terrible like one of the worst
comics has ever done comedy
and this one night she was killing I
mean [ __ ] killin and this is why when
she would hit a punch line
Joey was hiding behind the stage and he
was naked there you go close the
curtains and so she would get this giant
[ __ ] laugh and she was like wow and
she's like and then I told him [ __ ] you
know yes
balls ass naked and would that seems
like me in jail that seems criminal with
Joey's balls look like grapefruit and an
old lady's pantyhose and he's got a
giant dick so Joey would you know is he
got this huge belly so he opens up the
curtains his pants are down by his
ankles his balls Daan's dick or hanging
out as good this huge belly yeah she
never did comedy again really no okay
she should have larious that's in Austin
actually that was where we were at the
hotel hanging out in the that's our in
the background yeah hanging out at the
jacuzzi get ready for the show
Wow yeah today that I mean like comedies
it's already dangerous enough yeah I
don't need to add nudity well you get in
trouble now yeah it's like that like
people can get really angry at you for
showing your dick well that could it's
not not like the olden days it's kind of
a subtle gag it's a good we could see it
yeah it's a cool nobody cares guys yeah
you Joey used to do it all the time yeah
I don't there was I remember when I was
a kid I had older sisters and they there
was a flash of our neighborhood they
were going like oh the kite-flying I'm
like I don't understand this whole thing
I understand why he's doing that I don't
understand why it freaks you out so much
it's like I don't the whole thing but I
GU don't know I understand why it freaks
them I get the freaking out I still
don't get why they do it but I think it
has something to do with someone
traumatizing you when you're young it's
cut yeah it's gotta be humiliation
something you're addicted did that kind
of if there's lots of people like that
yeah well how about guys who are
addicted to they hire women to gag them
and [ __ ] on them and kick them in the
balls and yeah sometimes like really
powerful man and hurt them yeah yeah
hurt that stopped or not like stop on
their nuts with a stiletto
it starts bleeding how is that fun
how is that what is that I don't know
that is such an peep that is broke such
so down a rabbit all of you million you
know I mean I was hit a lot as I can
with the capitalist guy got all the
guilt and hitting invite and somehow I
managed to avoid that kind of that kind
of [ __ ] I don't have weird [ __ ] but
that's a mommy [ __ ] and it's like the
whole pantyhose and beating you and
kicking in the ball so it's like there's
obviously it's gotta be my dream of
pathologies that people can develop in
their life and it's probably a lot of
mental illness involved in there and
violence and abuse but apparently
there's a woman that I talked to who is
a dominatrix and she was telling me and
Jim Norton you know Jimmy hydrogen in a
dominant he loves dominatrix and she was
saying most of her clients are like
these like wealthy CEOs and they run
these companies and they're the [ __ ]
man and when they walk at home mr.
Olson's here hello mr. Wilson can I get
you a cup of coffee and everyone's
kissing their ass and they want someone
to [ __ ] on him like literally [ __ ] on
him they want someone to tie him up and
she yeah she would say that those are
the guys why is that though I guess it's
just so every powerful guy wants to like
feel a release of their power well
that's why when the John Wayne little
[ __ ] on I don't get it maybe the steel
dossier right when they were talking
about yeah stop getting peed on and all
that stuff for peeing on them that's why
it made sense it's like well of course
of course what not that it's real now
I'm gonna made sense of its real but
that would be a story because you expect
from a super powerful guy who had a
weird kink a super powerful guys with
weird kinks they usually want to get
pegged right they want to get pissed on
pegged is the best that's one of the
that's one of the best things like cuz
you could say pegged on national TV
right now yes still you can still say
pegged no one can stop you right peg
does not like it's not in the dictionary
I don't think right if you say but
[ __ ] with a dildo people go hey but
you shouldn't even say that because it's
too wordy the economy of words
pegged fits better and it's it's it's
got a P and a G pegged
how do you just not start laughing when
they let you start pegging you
I don't know how do you just not start
laugh it might be really into it
oh you're some a bad boy I what are the
women get out of it
did you get to dominate you and that's
it humiliate you yeah I knew a guy in
this group girl said that she would [ __ ]
him if if if he let her peg him and he
wouldn't do it oh really we're calling
he wanted to do it yeah well she said
she was I'll let you [ __ ] you me hug me
but I want to [ __ ] you in the ass huh
she she's pretty hot and all my friends
called him gay well bro you're gay hey
you should have just [ __ ] a letter in
the ass you're gay my friend it was
funny he was like it's not even a real
dick bro she probably doesn't want to
[ __ ] you but she's willing to do it if
you willing to do something for her she
probably always wanted a peg a guy you
got to make some sacrifices yeah it's
like your joke about the the female
version of who wants to give you a job
in Hollywood movie
Oh Harvey Nina Weinstein yeah yeah
Harvey Weinstein came to my son with a
solid contract I'd be like dude you're
gonna be Batman that's true we were
talking about that last night with our
Kelly like the our Kelly story is
horrific right he's having sexual 15 16
year-old girls but imagine if JLo had a
bunch of 15 and 16 year old boys locked
up in the house I'm wearing Miami she's
making them all eat her ass and
videotaping them we would be a little
happy
we'd be it's so funny it's so different
it is a different thing men and women
are different yeah they're a different
thing this idea that we're not different
it's so stupid
we're not math you know we're very
different right yeah but we're in denial
of that because we work in these
environments where men and women are
side by side forty hours a week and
everybody's under a human-resources
[ __ ] tight grip of behavior and so
everybody guys act weird and then men
don't want the women mad at them so they
have to pretend yeah these guys are
[ __ ] this guy's a total Pig yeah as
a male feminist I find that atrocious
you know who's not a male feminist you
know you never find it's a male feminist
gay guys
because they're not trying to [ __ ] you
okay so they don't have to play some
stupid game they care about women more
than they care about anything and
women's equality is the most important
thing no they're trying to suck dick and
blood [ __ ] dudes they're having a good
time that's what they do they're not
they're having a fun time with other gay
guys they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
want you to be victimized but they're
not gonna go out of their way as a male
ally that's all guys trying to [ __ ] you
a hundred percent it is 100 percent
sneaky guys who can't figure out any
other way to [ __ ] that they that they
pretend to be female allies or Seminole
feminists male Fateh you cannot be a
nice person who's got like good values
and ethics and you want things you want
equality for all but the idea that
you're a male feminist you come out I'm
a male feminist like just saying those
words out of your [ __ ] mouth you're a
sneaky [ __ ] I know what you're doing
you're sneaky so your gender traitor so
you're telling me that guys who say I
always thought feminism was just about
treating women equally that's because
you're talking to too many liberals what
is it about well it is about treating
people equally if you feel that it's
about treating people equally but when
you hear a man say that he's a male
feminist you're going so out on a limb
you're not just saying you're you I'm
all about treating people you you're
labeling yourself and you're labeling
yourself and this sort of submissive
sort of you're giving in to this
cultural wave so let me this can you
what is the definition of feminism is
that okay if I can have [ __ ] knows
right I mean he's gonna look it up right
I could ask siree I bet you she's yeah
yes sirree okay ready
we gotta end this soon I know hey Suri
what's the definition of feminism
advocacy advocacy of women's rights on
the basis of equality of the sexes boy
that's an open-ended saying right there
the quality the sex is how weightlifting
making babies there's no advocacy of
women's rights based on the Equality of
sexist notice of the sexes I think
you're equal but you can be equal but
different well we're not math right
certainly should have equal rights
we certainly should have just equal
build the way people treat each other
just equal morals and ethics another
definition of a material political
economic social equality of the sexes
organized activity on behalf of women's
rights and interests I mean that thought
sounds like [ __ ] that you would agree
with Joe well organized activity on baha
this is we're gonna this is gonna take
too long okay
unfortunately cuz it's three o'clock
okay but yeah I agree with most of those
things but I don't agree with is someone
labeling themselves that way that's a
man because everyone that I've ever met
is a little weasel well I'm Jay you know
I always say show me a male feminist
that can pick up heavy things and run
fast
they don't exist they don't exist
you think George Clooney calls himself a
feminist does he I don't have to
probably has to I think it's pegged yes
Jesus Christ like I'm going in Jamie I
love you we ought to do this more often
yes I believe we do this more often
always great to talk it's always great
to talk to you to tell everybody how to
get to show all your social media [ __ ]
everything jimmy dore comedy comm we're
on tour we're gonna be in Tempe Miami
all over the place go to jimmy dore calm
be calm and you'll see everything always
appreciated brother thank you so much
thank you bye you [ __ ]
[Music]